Binsackzimmern
Boiler
Zitronen
. ACL
Attacke
norte oval
Zitronen
N-n-n-n-nice!
So, exellent, gerade noch trinken geholt, wieder Treppe hochgeflitzt.
Hab ich hier, ja passt von der Entfernung her, exellent.
Hallo moin Leute, also wer ist denn hier alles am Start, dass die Salzwurst ist da, so kurz
Ärmel hochkrempeln hier, oder Ärmel hochkrempeln oder Holzfäller Look, könnt euch überlegen.
Die Salzwurst ja, Max Silbermann, Toxy, Kanetus, FakeNet, Tomtricks, Toxy, Mokuchan, The Driver, Nougat, Uga, was auch immer, DJ America,
Bitestrikes, alles am Start. Oh, ich hab hier kein FFZ installiert, das ist Fail. Ich muss, da muss ich den Chat hier doch aufmachen dann hier.
Ah, das ist wieder eine Playlist, die sich nicht entscheiden kann, wie laut es sein will. Huge.
Holzfäller Beste. Ja, das Problem am Holzfäller ist, ich müsste jetzt, damit ich ordentlich Holzfäller Style machen kann,
müsste ich den Kram hier zuknöpfen unten und ich bin, entweder möchte ich das Hemd wieder ausziehen, aber ich bin nicht zu faul für.
Ich krieg's nicht gebacken, den Kram hier, also ich hab, also ich hab, oh es ruckelt, null. Alter, was ist los? Warum lagts?
Anzeige ist raus, was soll das hier. Ich verfüge nicht über den Skill, bei angezogenem Hemd die Knöpfe zuzumachen. Kann ich nicht.
Weiß überhaupt nicht, ob es Leute gibt, die das können.
Vielleicht dünne, dünne China-Chinesen, die halt quasi ganz dünne Ärmchen haben, sodass es im Prinzip doppelt um den Arm rumpasst, sodass du es dann von oben machen kannst.
Ich weiß es nicht. Handgelegt, ja, kommt ab und zu mal hier im Stream vor.
Okay, oh, na nee, ich hab keinen Bock Headset zu entwirren. Vielleicht wenn ich was runterschmeiße, muss ich gleich nochmal Headset entwirren.
So Leute, ich zeige euch jetzt mal was, also was wir heute machen ist folgendes, heute wird es etwas advanceder.
Ich krieg das nicht hin, ich kann das nicht.
Aber es wird auch ohne zugeknöpftes Hemd funktionieren, ich mach einfach die Ärmel hoch.
Also heute wird es etwas advanceder und zwar haben wir heute mehrere Sachen auf dem Programm und zwar, ich zeige euch das mal, ich mach mal kurz Bildkurs.
Ich sollte vielleicht nicht an der Kamera wackeln.
Hier ist eine Stichkante, das passt, wie ich es eingestellt habe.
Wann der Wurst League kommt, brauche ich einfach das Onlyfans Account für, sonst wäre ich gebannt. Und das glaubt mir, das will wahrscheinlich keiner von euch sehen. Also, da muss man erstmal darauf verzichten.
Gachibas.
So, gut, ich muss mal kurz diesen Klempel hier ein bisschen weg machen, das liegt dezent im Weg. Also ich zeige euch mal kurz was wir heute machen.
Also wir haben heute drei Sachen vor. Erstens, wir fangen mit LEDs für Weihnachten an, aber wir haben mehrere Sachen vor, ich leg das mal kurz hier oben hin.
Das erste ist, also nicht der Reihenfolge, wie wir es durchführen im Stream. Aufräumen in der Cam. Nö, wo soll man da aufräumen? Achso, hier meinst du ja.
Also das erste was wir machen, also nicht Reihenfolge vom Stream, wir flashen heute endlich mal mit der neuen Firmware die Dinger.
Junge, heute Re-Live-Stream, ja mach ich öfters, mach ich öfters. Wir flashen heute endlich diese Dinger mal. Das sind Thermostate, ähm, ne nicht Thermostate, Thermostate ist das falsche Wort.
Thermometer und Luftdrucksensoren. Kostet 2,50 Euro bei Aliexpress, lässt sich flashen mit Custom Firmware, das Problem war nur wer den letzten Stream vielleicht verfolgt hat.
Die haben die Geräte halb kaputt gemacht, weil die Firmware nicht für die Revision ausgelegt war, die ich bestellt habe bei Aliexpress. Aber ich habe dem Programmierer von dieser Open Source Firmware, habe ich drei Geräte geschickt.
Und man muss echt sagen, die sind wirklich auf Zack. Alle beide, gibt ja zwei Alternativen, also eine Firmware Fork vom anderen. Und die haben den neuen Display Controller eingebaut, das heißt jetzt sind die flashbar.
Äh ja und es gibt eine Custom Firmware, die die Einstellungen speichert, habe ich letztens gesehen, hat er gepusht.
Hast du die drei wieder zurück? Ne, die will ich auch nicht wieder zurück, habe ich ihm auch gesagt, die kann er behalten. 2,50 Euro Leute, scheiß drauf, ist ja Fire für einen guten Zweck.
Der kann die bestimmt auch gebrauchen.
Ne, die will ich auch nicht wieder zurück haben.
So, also das ist es als eine Sache, die wir heute machen. Die nächste Sache ist, Moment, Sekunde, ich muss mal kurz den Amazon Karton holen.
Ich habe eingekauft Leute, nachdem das Flaschen gestern geklappt hat, ich habe mir eine gekauft.
Ich habe mir noch eine gekauft. Ich habe mir noch eine gekauft. Ich habe mir noch eine gekauft. Jetzt passt hier nicht mehr hin.
Ich mache das mal kurz wieder weg. Ich habe mir noch eine gekauft, noch eine gekauft, noch eine gekauft und noch eine gekauft.
Und jetzt habe ich euch gebadet, weil ich habe euch die gleichen Steckdosenleisen doppelt gezeigt.
Aber ich habe mir fünf Stück bestellt. Ich habe mir fünf Stück bestellt. Die müssen wir heute auch noch flashen.
Aber womit ich anfangen will, weil ich es auch schon eine Weile nicht mehr gemacht habe, sind LEDs oder RGB-LEDs besser gesagt.
Ich war die ganze Zeit schon auf einer Suche, was für meinen Weihnachtsbaum bzw. für Weihnachtsbeleuchtung.
Wie viele Steckdosen willst du haben? Max, Antwort Ja. Alter, das ist ja, dieses Comment ist noch nicht mal auf YouTube-Meter.
Cringe, wie man dazu heutzutage sagt. Wobei, Leute, ich habe euch gesagt, Jugendwort des Jahres, als das zur Wahl stand.
Ich habe gesagt, ich bin für Cringe. Und was gewinnt? Cringe. So muss das sein.
Die haben sicherlich mal einen Stream geguckt. Das Gremium hat doch eh keine Ahnung davon.
Dann ist es besser, die hören auf irgendwie den 37-jährigen Boomer auf Twitch, als müsste ich was über Jugend sprachen.
Die wissen nicht mal, was Cringe bedeutet. Das gehe ich auch mal von aus, dass sie nicht wissen, was Cringe bedeutet.
So, jetzt krempeln wir hier mal kurz ein bisschen hoch. Kein Holzfelder-Look mehr.
So. Und als erstes, wir anfangen. Der Eislux fragt, wer nutzt denn noch LEDs?
Also ich nutze OLED für das perfekte Schwarz am PC. Auch an deinem Weihnachtsbaum.
Ich gebe zu, Kontrast bei den Farben ist am Weihnachtsbaum besonders wichtig.
Ausrufezeichen Server, das stimmt übrigens gar nicht mehr. Ausrufezeichen Server können wir löschen. Den Server gibt es nicht mehr.
So, und jetzt zeige ich euch mal die LEDs. Hier. Ich habe alles, was wir brauchen, hier schon hingelegt.
Also, das hier. Das hier ist der LED-Streifen, den ich mir gekauft habe. Man erkennt das kaum, ne? Aber schaut mal her.
Das hier. Das hier ist die LED. Und das dazwischen sind halt die Datenkabel. Und was ist das erste, was man sich jetzt fragt, wenn man sowas hier sieht?
Mit so. Also das erste, was mich fragt ist, warum gibt das keinen Kurzschluss?
Das gibt keinen Kurzschluss, weil die China-Chinesen relativ clever sind. Und die haben das hier in irgendein Moment.
Die haben die LED in irgendein komisches Kunstharz gepackt. Und die haben die Kabel lackiert oder so, würde ich sagen.
Dass es eben keinen Kurzschluss gibt. Das heißt, das hier auf dieser kleinen Rolle sind 5 Meter LEDs. Das ist eine 5 Meter LED-Kette.
Und die passt glaube ich wunderbar zum Beispiel an den Weihnachtsbaum, weil das fällt halt da nicht so auf.
Viel besser als irgendwie so fette Kabel da drüber zu legen. Und das probieren wir heute mal aus.
Wenn wir flashen WLED und probieren das mal aus. Ich habe hier einmal noch einen ESP8266 Demo on Mini.
Das ist der, wo ich mir den 10er-Pack bestellt habe. Können wir gleich mal einen verwenden.
Dann, ganz wichtig, gab es gratis dabei einen Anschluss. Das stand ganz groß dabei.
Gratis Gift stand dabei. Sie haben mir doch einen Anschluss geschenkt.
Also wenn das mal nicht der Gönner-Modus aktiviert ist bei den Chinesen, dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Dann habe ich hier so eine IP54-Box. Der Mauszeiger ist da übrigens ziemlich dumm platziert.
Warum geht jetzt das X da oben? Jetzt geht das X weg.
Also, IP54-Box und so einen Anschluss fürs Netzteil im Endeffekt.
Das löten wir heute mal dran und schließen das an und gucken mal, ob das was taugt.
Ich habe hier selbst keine Ahnung. Also ihr seht, ich habe es noch nicht angeschlossen.
Hier ist es noch komplett, so wie es aus der Packung kam.
Ich habe legit absolut keine Ahnung, ob diese Dinger was taugen.
Ob die überhaupt funktionieren. Dass sie funktionieren, würde ich jetzt mal annehmen.
Keine Ahnung. Machst du das mit WLED? Yes.
Zum Glück habe ich daumenhoch mittlerweile auch verbotene Geste oder darf man das noch mal machen?
Da bin ich leider nicht so up to date, was da gerade in Verruf geraten ist oder nicht.
Womit speist du die? Ich habe hier ein Sack. Wo habe ich es? Netzteil, zeige ich dir gleich.
Das ist maßlos oversized das Netzteil. Ich sage es gleich, aber zum Testen ist es auf jeden Fall
mehr als genug.
Moment.
Ich kann es eigentlich erst später holen. Die LEDs werden hier mit dem Netzteil.
Alter warum leckt das, wenn die Kamera fokussiert? 5 Volt, 10 Ampere.
Das ist viel, viel zu viel. So viel braucht man da gar nicht.
Die geben selbst auf der Packung an, glaube ich, max 15 Watt oder so.
Ich habe die Packung leider schon weggeschmissen hiervon. Oder zumindest nicht gerade hier.
Ich glaube die ist wirklich im Müll schon. Also sprich 5 Volt, 3 Ampere Netzteil gut ist.
Also das ist maßlos oversized das Netzteil. Aber zum Testen ist es natürlich wunderbar.
Können wir mal gucken, wie hell das maximal wird. So jetzt muss ich mal gucken, wo ich das Netzteil hinlege.
Ohne dass es mir runterfällt.
Einfach auf die Erd hier.
So, ich würde sagen damit fangen wir an.
Das probieren wir aus, weil da bin ich wirklich selbst äußerst gespannt drauf, wie das funktioniert.
Das erste was wir machen müssen ist, ich muss erstmal meine Steckdosen aus dem Weg räumen.
Die liegen hier ein bisschen, da liegt so eine fette Amazon Kiste mit den 5 Steckdosen drin.
Hallo Max, gab es jetzt eine Steckdose, die Max geflasht bekommen hat? Ja, gab es gestern im Stream.
Die hier guck.
Die hier. Die haben wir gestern geflasht. Hat funktioniert.
Und davon habe ich mir jetzt 5 Stück bestellt.
Du hast letztens deinen 63 Ampere Netzteil getestet und kurzschluss gemacht.
Du könntest auch einen YouTube Channel aufmachen mit sowas.
Wir haben noch letztens ein Video gesehen, wo irgendein Typ gesagt hat, er schmilzt jetzt einen Löffel mit Strom.
Weiß ich wie weit man mit 63 Ampere kommt?
Hängt wahrscheinlich schon ein bisschen von der Spannung ab.
Aber kann man bestimmt schon ein paar Clickbait Videos generieren draus.
So, ich leg das mal wieder hier neben hin. Auf den riesen Haufen Zeug.
Okay, wir fangen mal an mit den LEDs.
Das erste was wir machen müssen ist, wir müssen den ESP auspacken und flashen.
Mal gucken, ob das so aufgeht. Nein.
Und wisst ihr was das Beste ist? Ich hab keine Schere da.
Deswegen machen wir das jetzt, wie die Experten das so machen.
Ich leg ihn da einfach ein Loch rein und mach es dann auf.
Only Profis dürfen das so machen.
Also das ist only high IQ geht das.
Alle anderen sollten eine Schere verwenden.
So, hier haben wir einen ganz billigen ESP 82, äh, ja, 82, 66.
Wenn das sich fokussiert, dann kann ich euch das zeigen.
Da.
Auf einem Devon Mini Fake Board.
Das ist kein originaler Devon Mini, geh ich mal ganz stark davon aus.
Bestimmt, bestimmt Fake. Ja, steht noch nicht mal Hersteller drauf.
Alles Fake, aber ist mir egal.
Was bei den Pins interessant ist für uns.
Und dann mal Big Brain Frage an den Chat.
Welche Pins werden wir hiervon brauchen?
Wir haben einmal zu bieten einen Crown Pin, 5 Volt Pin, 3,3 Volt Pin.
Ähm, serielle Schnittsteller, ADC und GPIO Pins.
Was brauchen wir dafür? Wer hat beim letzten Stream aufgepasst?
Crown, Crown brauchen wir auf jeden Fall. Crown 5 Volt, das klingt schon mal gut.
Ja, wir brauchen Crown 5 Volt und einen GPIO Pin, irgendeinen.
Ich glaube GPIO 2 ist wie LED standardmäßig.
Was ich da dran anschließen will?
Na ja, LEDs.
LEDs, WS, was sind denn das? WS 2812 oder so.
Also man braucht 5 Volt und Crown, korrekt?
Allerdings 5 Volt in dem Fall als Input.
Also angeschlossen wird das später so.
Ich leg das mal kurz hin.
Hier kommt das Netzteil rein. Das ist so ein...
Wie nennt man das eigentlich?
Das hat bestimmt irgendeinen Standard oder so.
Hier kommt das Netzteil dran.
Hier ist Crown.
So, und das wird dann so angeschlossen.
Das wird dann hier angeschlossen.
Crown plus 5 Volt, so.
Und hier kommt dann der ESP dran.
Mit einer Datenleitung.
Und die andere Seite schließen wir wahrscheinlich auch noch hier an,
weil bei 5 Meter ist der Widerstand im Kabel meistens so groß,
dass die hinteren LEDs nicht mehr so richtig farbecht sind.
Hohlstecker.
Ja, Hohlstecker kenn ich auch, aber ich dachte, da gibt es irgendwie, was weiß ich,
IsoDin85750.ax oder so.
Aber anscheinend ja nicht.
So, jetzt flashen wir das Ding erst mal.
Ohne Flaschen geht hier nix.
Und ich hoffe, der Scheiß funktioniert, nicht wie das letzte Mal.
Also, Flascherino, wo ist mein USB-Kabel für das Flaschen?
Hier.
Ich muss kurz die Musik vorspulen.
Ein bisschen zackigeres.
Ja, besser.
Okay, also ich schließe das jetzt mal an meinen Rechner an und dann flashen wir das.
Wisst ihr, was wir machen können?
Wisst ihr, was ich noch gar nicht ausprobiert habe?
Wir können das mal über den Raspberry Pi machen.
Ich habe den ja hier liegen von gestern.
Hier haben wir wieder unseren, der heimliche MVP eines jeden Streams,
Small Access Point von Raspberry Pi 4.
Den brauchen wir eigentlich später zum Flaschen,
aber wir können dann mal damit gucken, ob wir da direkt den ESP mitflaschen können.
Mein Gen tut das, ist mir auch klar, aber habe ich noch nicht gemacht.
Mal gucken, ob wir da, ja, müssen wir mal gucken.
Ich muss erst mal Strom anschließen an den Raspberry Pi, dass das funktioniert.
Strom an und hier da, guckt.
Leuchtet, blutet.
Machen wir mal da drüber.
Der Chain Law ist da, Porg.
Hier, ESP.
Ich leg das mal so hin, dass es keinen Kurzschluss gibt oder so.
Schließen wir an.
Na.
So.
Der blinkt jetzt und bootet, aber da macht nichts, weil da ist ja keine Firmware drauf.
Das ist der Unterschied zum Raspberry Pi oder so.
Hier ist halt kein Betriebssystem drauf.
Es bootet quasi direkt in die Firmware und dann fürzt das aus
und macht da nicht irgendwie Multitasking oder irgendwie anderes Gedöns.
Okay, probieren wir das mal hier drüber zu flaschen.
Ich meine, wir können das mit dem ESP-Tool flaschen, das ist das einfachste.
Wir können aber auch mal gucken.
Ich habe Thesmotizer noch nie auf dem Raspberry Pi gemacht.
Das können wir mal ausbringen.
Was wir heute machen, Kurzfassung, erst mal LED-Leiste,
dann flaschen die Thermostate mit der neuesten Firmware
und wenn ich dann noch Bock habe, noch fünf Steckdosen leisten, die ich mir bestellt habe.
Vielleicht hebe ich mir das eine auch auf, je nachdem, wie schnell das funktioniert,
wie gut das klappt.
Der Flashchamp ist wieder am Start.
Das ist ein guter Titel heute.
Flashchamp.
Das schreibe ich jetzt in den Titel rein.
Flashchamp am Start.
Dann brauchen wir irgendein passendes Emoji für.
Ja, perfekt.
Flashchamp wieder am Start.
Weichern.
Exzellent, exzellent.
Okay, loggen wir uns mal auf den Raspberry Pi ein.
Ich hoffe, die IP stimmt, aber ich gehe mal von aus, wenn das in der History ist.
Cat, so, das ist der Raspberry Pi 4.
Model B REF 1.1.
Da muss man ja ganz korrekt sein hier.
Ohje, was ist hier los?
Oh, habt ihr gesehen?
Das Aufwellein-Meme-Board wäre fast abgekackt.
Das ist laggy, AF.
Warum laggt es?
Was ist hier los?
Warum ist das so laggy?
Funktioniert doch.
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Haben die vielleicht Tesmotizer direkt?
Direkt drinne hier?
Das wäre ja witzig.
Gibt es das überhaupt als Pi-Build?
Schauen wir mal.
Nee, wäre auch lustig, wenn es das gäbe.
Warum gibt es das nur als Windows-Binary?
Wollen die mich veräppeln?
Muss ich das jetzt über PIP installieren?
Oh, okay.
Dann installen wir von PIP.
Auch okay.
Sag mal, ich mache ja nicht viel mit Python,
aber mal so an die Python-Kenner.
Was hat PIP für einen Ruf in der Python-Community?
Also, ich habe, wie gesagt, nicht so viel damit gemacht,
aber ich hatte das, was ich bisher mitgemacht habe,
eher so den Eindruck, PIP ist eines der Schwächen von Python.
Der Rest wunderbar, aber so der Package-Manager
ist irgendwie nicht ganz so 2021, wie man das gerne hätte.
PIP ist so, la, la, okay.
Na ja, installieren wir mal.
Ja, geht so.
PIP ist Pain's Champ.
Was benutzt man denn ansonsten, wenn PIP Pain's Champ ist?
Ich meine, in Python gibt es ja für alles 50 Billarden Alternativen.
Anaconda? Hä, nee, oder?
Also, früher gab es PIP und es gab Auto, Auto-Setup oder wie das.
Monkeys?
Ist das jetzt gut oder schlecht?
Was hat?
Ah, yes, Compiler-Arrows, perfekt.
Ich meine, wir müssen das nicht auf dem Raspberry Pi machen.
Wir können das ohne Probleme auf meinem Desktop machen, ja.
Was ist das? Was, was, was will der hier?
Hab ich, oh, oh.
Ai, ai, ai.
Hab ich, hab ich, was?
Build API has no attribute.
Oh je, oh je, was ist das hier?
Die haben einige Probleme auf dem Raspberry Pi, okay.
Desmotizer Pi, ich hab das noch nie.
Ich wollte das mal damit auch.
Ich meine, ich kann einfach das ESP-Tool nehmen.
Das ist easy as fuck, ja.
Wir machen es im Zweifelsfall auf dem ESP-Tool,
aber ich hab mir überlegt, vielleicht geht das ja.
Auto-Flash, Desmotizer, geht das da überhaupt drauf?
Feuer Upgrade, ne, das ist eigentlich relativ aktuell.
Mal gucken, mal gucken, was der macht.
Wir gucken mal, was der macht.
Er installt irgendwelche Dependencies, okay.
Er lebt auch noch, er macht Dinger.
Die Animation ist ein bisschen laggy, aber gut.
Ich muss mich mal kurz nebenbei mit ASCII-Quarium beruhigen.
Perfekt, weiter geht's.
Was flashst du?
Jetzt erst mal das Motor auf einen normalen ESP für die LED-Kette.
Danach flashen wir das Thermostat.
Wenn ich da noch Bock habe, flashen wir noch ein paar Steckdosenleisten.
Die einzigen, die noch funktionieren von Amazon.
Da bin ich ja froh, dass ich die gefunden hab.
So.
Hi, was geht?
Was macht er?
Zack, wir schauen mal kurz, wir schauen mal kurz, was er macht.
Er macht 100% CPU, Python 3, ah gut.
Dann soll er mal machen.
Ist die 10er-Packung der Leisten angekommen?
Ja, aber es war keine 10er-Packung.
Ich hab nur 5 bestellt.
Der Herrscher ist am Start.
Poggers, danke für den Zap.
Dann kann das Motor flashen direkt übers Web.
Nee, das funktioniert nicht.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Wir können es gleich mal ausbringen, aber aus irgendwelchen Gründen hat bei mir
Browser-USB nicht funktioniert auf dem Raspberry Pi.
Wo ist die Musik?
Irgendwelche Nintendo-Sachen.
Muss man mal genauer sagen, eine Playlist.
Okay, er hat es angeblich.
What?
Alter, was will er von mir?
Was, was, was willst du, was möchte er mir sagen?
Hab ich keine Build-Tools vielleicht?
Abinstall, Build Essentials.
Essentials.
Da hab ich keinen Compiler-Geduld installiert.
Doch.
Machs doch einfach auf den PC.
Nee, ich will das jetzt ausprobieren, ob das funktioniert.
Kann man bei der Steckdose alle Steckdosen einzeln steuern?
Ja.
Das ist das Gute daran.
Dass das funktioniert.
Ich hab ja gestern auch eine geflasht.
Ach, jetzt.
Okay, okay.
Wir machen jetzt, wir machen das nicht.
Also auf dem PC können wir es immer noch machen.
Wir haben jetzt zwei Varianten.
Wir flashen direkt mit ESP-Tool.
Oder wir gucken, ob über USB im Browser noch funktioniert.
Das probieren wir jetzt aus.
Da bin ich mal gespannt.
Ich hab das noch nie gemacht über den Raspberry Pi.
Weil mit ESP-Tool muss es funktionieren.
ESP-Tool hab ich schon mal verwendet auf dem Raspberry Pi.
Wie heißt die Steckerleiste?
Kann ich dir zeigen?
Ich hab das heute gepostet auf Twitter.
Kannst du bei mir auf Twitter vorbeigucken?
Und natürlich auch gleich followen.
Ach ja.
Dazu, dazu, übrigens, wo ich gerade dabei bin.
Dazu mach ich nächste Woche Sellout-Stream.
CACW as a Service.
Ghost-Startup in den USA.
Bald, bald ist hier To the Moon.
CACW as a Service läuft dann in den USA für einen Stream lang.
Ich installiere nicht systemweit.
Installiere in meinem Heimatverzeichnis, weil ich PIP als normaler User ausführe.
So, hier, da, hier ist der Link zur Steckerleiste.
Leider, ich bilde mir einen leider schon etwas teurer geworden im Vergleich zum ersten.
Die zu ersten, die ich mir gekauft hab.
Vielleicht haben wir die Stonks erhöht dadurch.
Verstanden, was das QMAC nicht da ist.
Ja, ich installiere mal Qt gleich.
Was zum Geier treibt der da?
Nee, das ist mir zu dumm.
Ich probiere das jetzt, ich probiere das jetzt über X-Forwarding und Firefox.
Ah, nicht da.
Chrome.
Ist der Chrome eigentlich auch ein Snap auf dem Raspberry Pi?
Oder ist das so ein reines Ubuntu-Geschiss?
Okay, schauen wir mal, ob es funktioniert.
Connect ESP-Device to your computer using Hammer gemacht.
Select Firma-Variant.
Ja, install.
Ja, wie?
Aha.
Oh.
Welches ist es denn?
Ich flasche jetzt nicht random eines der Devices.
Ich muss erst mal kurz gucken, welches es ist.
Ich gucke erst mal, welches das ist.
Moment.
SSH.
LSUSP.
Es ist ein...
Ach so, nee.
Oh fuck, das vergesse ich immer, wie man das sieht.
Also, hier.
Das ist die Geschichte.
Wir gucken einfach mal.
Hier, zack.
DTY-USB ist es.
Okay.
Fuck.
Das hätte ich...
Also, random irgendwas sinnlos flaschen will ich nicht.
So.
Also, install das Motor auf TTY-USB 0.
Snap ist zum Glück nur Ubuntu, ja Gott sei Dank.
Alla Snap ist so ein pains-Champ.
Hat Pip eigentlich hin...
Warum gehst du einfach zu?
Hat Pip eigentlich jetzt hinbekommen?
Wo installiert er den Kram überhaupt hin?
Local?
Wo installiert...
Wohin installiert denn Pip überhaupt?
Nö, er hat überhaupt nichts installiert.
Er hat gedacht...
Pip hat sich gedacht...
Hat er keinen Bock, jetzt die Musik wieder so laut?
Was ist das für eine Playlist?
Können die die Musik nicht?
Ich einfach mal gleich laut machen?
Das ist das Mindeste, was ich von so einer Playlist erwarte, dass er die Musik ungefähr lautstärker angepasst hat.
So, also das Motor hier, Reset Settings to default.
Ja, meinetwegen.
Install TTY-USB, connect.
Das funkt, nice.
Guck mal hier.
Es flashort.
Man sieht das nicht, da macht nichts.
Beim Flaschen.
Aber scheint zu funktionieren.
Huge, nice.
Ist die Steckerleiste nach dem Flaschen auch per Alexa steuerbar?
Nein.
Das ist mir aber auch ganz recht.
Credo, danke für den Sub.
So pauschal, stimmt das zwar, aber natürlich, wenn du eine Heimautomatisierung hast, die mit Alexa verbunden hast,
da kannst du natürlich auch die Steckdosenleiste damit steuern.
Das funktioniert schon.
Aber es geht halt nicht mehr mit der offiziellen App und dann irgendwie Alexa, wie heißt das, Skill, glaube ich, verbinden.
Den neuen Portal-Trailer.
Nee, den haben wir, glaube ich, nicht geguckt.
Okay, Donen ist es alles.
Alles Donen.
Also, ESP ist geflasht.
Dann können wir jetzt ja mal zu Tatl schreiten.
Das heißt, ich sollte jetzt auf meinem...
Oh, nee.
Zack, ich habe mein iPad wieder vergessen.
Ich muss mal kurz Tablet holen.
Ich brauche das Tablet, um Tasmota in den Access Point zu packen.
Alles klar.
Also, Access Point ist am Start.
Access Point braucht Strom, sonst funktioniert das Ganze natürlich nicht.
Access Point, Strom.
ESP macht man immer falsch rum dran.
Ich gehe mal ein bisschen aus dem W-Excess Point.
Das Small Access Point, ja.
So, und wenn das Flaschen geklappt hat, müsste ich jetzt im W-Lan...
Ich zeige euch das gleich.
Hab ich mir gestern schon gesehen, aber ich zeige es nochmal.
Ja, Tasmota.
Achtung.
Flaschen hat geklappt.
Select your Wi-Fi Home Network.
Nein, nein, ich blende euch das nicht jetzt ein.
Es gibt einen neuen Assistent für Tasmota jetzt.
Das finde ich gut.
Guck mal, es gibt jetzt einen neuen Assistent für Tasmota.
Jetzt müssen wir schauen, ob der Access Point da ist.
Access Point.
Das ist falsch.
Es ist 37.
Ah ja.
Ja.
Access Point ist am Start IP DHCP Server Leases.
Und jetzt logge ich mich mal ein.
Und jetzt sollte hier eigentlich das neue Tasmota Ding aufploppen.
Achtung.
Safe.
Wenn ich mich nicht verschrie...
Da ist er.
Bam.
Komische Sortierung.
Da ist er.
Da ist unser ESP.
Alter Firefox, komm on.
Ja.
Das ist unser ESP.
Also das ist das Webinterface auf diesem Ding hier, wo wir gerade drauf sind.
Schau mal, was mit Tuya Convert gemacht.
Ja, gestern.
Also hier ist das alles drauf.
Das ist das Webinterface und das können wir jetzt...
Warum flash ich das eigentlich mit Tasmota?
Bin ich bescheuert?
Ich muss das mit WLED flashen.
Chat.
Was ist heute los?
Warum sagt mir das keiner?
Warum flash ich das mit Tasmota?
Das ist falsch.
Es haben nicht...
Es haben einfach nicht genug Leute Prime-Subscribed.
Wenn die Prime-Subscriber vorher da waren, dann ist das kein Problem.
Weil ihr wisst ja, durch jeden Sekunde, durch jeden Prime-Sub, erholt sich der Chat-IQ.
Also der...
Wie heißt der?
Der kommunative...
Kommulative...
Kommulativ heißt, glaube ich, die Kombination aller IQs im Chat.
Und hätten zwei Leute Prime-Subbed, dann hätte das auch geklappt.
Und der Chat hat mir rechtzeitig Bescheid gesagt.
Aber so war es ja nichts, ne?
Bits.
Ja, das...
Bits, Bits ist schwierig.
Aber trotzdem danke für die Bits.
Aber Bits ist schwierig.
Eigentlich, eigentlich helfen nur, nur Subs und Prime-Subs.
So, jetzt haben wir das vollkommen umsonst gemacht.
Das heißt, wir brauchen W-LED, siehste?
Weil wir wollen ja LEDs dran machen.
Ich hab zu viel das Motor geflasht in letzter Zeit.
NoLedge.de
Also runterladen.
W-LED-Beta-Version.
Nein.
Wir nehmen nicht die Beta-Version.
Wir nehmen die reguläre Latest-Kari.
Ok, japanische Aussprache.
Wahrscheinlich Hikari oder so.
ESP32 brauchen wir nicht.
Wir brauchen den ESP82-66-Bin-Copy-Link.
Wir machen es jetzt doch mit dem ESP-Tool.
Wir machen die Nupe-Variante.
Die Variante, die auf jeden Fall funktioniert.
E-Ged.
W-LED runterladen.
ESP-Tool.
Ab-Search.
Gibt's das da?
ESP-Tool.
Ab-Install.
Ach, kennt ihr das übrigens?
Was ist denn das jetzt?
Wer will denn jetzt was?
Alter, ich fass es nicht.
Sick.
So.
Passt.
Also, ja.
Wer kennt den Trick?
Jetzt haben wir es vertan.
Sudo, Ausrufezeichen, Ausrufezeichen.
Bam.
Die RGB-Polizei.
Ja, die wird es sein.
Genau.
Sudo, Ausrufezeichen, Ausrufezeichen.
Da kann man das letzte Befehl noch mal ausführen.
Z-Option 78.1 und dann W-LED über die Tasmotagui flashen.
Ach, was.
Wir flashen das jetzt so.
Was macht denn das?
Windows.
E.
Sticky keys.
Was ist denn Z-Option 78?
Z-Option Tasmot.
Das muss ich mir jetzt mal angucken.
Da lernt man vielleicht noch was.
Z-Option.
Was für eine Z-Option 78?
Ist ja überhaupt nicht kryptisch.
Gibt es überhaupt nicht.
Gebaidet.
78.
Gibt es nicht.
Der Chat hat mich massiv gebaidet.
So.
Funktioniert nicht.
Aber ich flash das eh so.
Also ESP-Tool.
Boah, ESP-Tool-Options, Alter.
ESP-Tool, W-LED, keine Ahnung.
Install W-LED-Binary.
Jaja, machen wir.
Flitz.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Vicky is now deep gated.
Was ist denn hier los?
ESP-Tool.
Write flash.
Genau das wollen wir haben.
Also ESP-Tool.
Write flash.
W-LED.
So.
Ach.
Naja, es heißt einfach nur ESP-Tool.
Er erkennt auch, dass es DevTools USB ist und jetzt wird geflashed.
War das die heiße Nachbarin?
Ja, das wär schön.
Also ich hab keine heiße Nachbarin.
Aber selbst alles, was in dieser Straße infrage kommen würde dafür, war es nicht.
Wahrscheinlich ist das Z-Option 76 oder so, er hat sich einfach nur vertan.
So, jetzt flashen wir W-LED.
Ja, jetzt flashen wir auch das Richtige.
Hätte der Chat aufgepasst, hätten wir uns jetzt 15 Minuten gespart.
Es ist wirklich, also manchmal ist es wirklich schlimm.
Wie soll man hier in Ruhe streamen?
Ich fass es nicht.
Bring die Leute nicht auf blöde Ideen.
Mittlerweile kommt es ja in Deutschland sogar manchmal vor.
Schlimm eigentlich.
Aber ich hab den Eindruck, das hat den USA auch ein bisschen nachgelassen.
Die haben wahrscheinlich festgestellt, dass es richtig, richtig Ärger gibt,
wenn man im Knast landet, wenn man so einen Scheiß macht.
Das muss ich hier erstmal noch.
Guck mal, es leuchtet blau.
Einfach so, random.
Kann ich mich jetzt einloggen, W-LED?
Ich guck mal, ob es jetzt ein W-LED gibt.
W-LED-AP, jawoll.
Was ist denn das Default-W-LED-Passwort?
Was ist das Default-W-LED-Passwort?
Das Passwort ist W-LED1234.
Sehr gutes Passwort, hätte von mir sein können.
Ah, funktioniert, Leute. Schaut mal her.
Wir haben es geflasht.
Poggers.
W-LED am Start.
Auf dem ESP.
Jetzt können wir anfangen.
Vielleicht sollte ich aber erst nochmal Wi-Fi-Settings bei mir ins Netzwerk hauen,
dass ich es danach verwenden kann.
Access Point aufmachen. Der ECP-Server liest es.
Ich melde das jetzt mal schnell an.
Wi-Fi-Settings, SSID.
Zumindest eine dumme Idee, SSIDs groß zu schreiben.
Die lassen sich auf dem Tablet schlecht eingeben.
DHCP, Subnet Mask, MDNS, braucht kein Mensch.
W-LED, was ist das?
Vitas Motor für...
Äh, ja, so ungefähr.
Ich kann es dir mal schnell zeigen.
Hier, das ist W-LED.
Das ist quasi...
Naja, es ist nicht Vitas Motor, das stimmt nicht.
Es ist eine Custom-Firmware, die für LED-Steuerung ausgelegt ist.
Sieht dann so aus und kannst sie hier dran rumbasteln.
So, jetzt müssen wir erstmal in die Config...
Wow, jetzt haben wir eine gute Maschine.
Okay, das kann man nicht kleiner machen.
LED-Preferences.
Musste man da nicht einstellen?
Hier, hier kann man nämlich einstellen, was für LEDs das sind.
Aber das ist richtig, das sind die richtigen LEDs.
Das passt.
Wir stellen jetzt noch einen Total-LED-Count in 50.
50 LEDs, Maximum, Current, ist mir doch egal.
Aus, kein Limit, Alter, wer braucht da einen Limit?
Color, RGB-Ordner, Pin 2.
Pin 2 ist wichtig, das müssen wir uns merken, wo wir das anschließen.
Ja, das passt, glaube ich.
Die Fall-Brightness 255, was denn sonst?
Ich glaube, wir haben alles.
Gut, jetzt können wir anfangen mit den LEDs.
Also, W-LED haben wir am Start.
Jetzt mache ich den Raspberry Pi mal weg.
Also, das ist ein schlechter Fake.
Das Ding hat nichts gescheites, wo man das angreifen kann zum Rausziehen.
So, hier so, hier so vielleicht so.
Ach, scheiß drauf.
Das war schon kurzschlussfabriziert.
Ich meine, man hätte natürlich auch USB vorher rausziehen können.
So, Raspberry Pi.
Schmeißen wir den mal in die Eck.
So, dass er nicht runterfällt.
Okay, und jetzt kümmern wir uns mal um die LEDs.
Access Point fliegt auch mal kurz weg.
Alles klar.
Ich hoffe, man erkennt alles.
Also, das ist hier eine LED-Lichterkette.
Die hat ganz klein, ich habe es zwar eben schon mal gezeigt, aber ich zeige es jetzt noch mal schnell.
Die hat ganz klein solche LEDs hier.
Das da, in diesem Pack sind die LEDs.
Und das drumherum ist lackiertes Kabel, dass es keinen Kurzschluss gibt.
Das heißt, das ist wunderbar für so Kleinkram, wie zum Beispiel Weihnachtsbaum.
Wo man nicht irgendwie fette LED-Ketten machen will, weil das Problem ist halt an Steuerbaren-LEDs.
Ihr seht, das sind mindestens drei Kabel.
Und das ist meistens richtig fett.
Und dann hängt da ein ganzer Baum voll mit irgendwelchen Kabel.
So.
Und jetzt, ich glaube, ich lasse das sogar mal so zusammen.
Obwohl ich mir da nicht sicher bin.
Soll ich es auseinander machen oder soll ich es zusammen lassen?
Zum Basteln ist zusammenlassen definitiv besser.
Aber falls der Lack irgendwo einen Fehler hat, ist es halt vielleicht, weiß nicht.
Ich lasse erst mal so.
Ja, ich glaube, ich lasse erst mal so.
Okay, dann lass mal kurz überlegen.
Wie fangen wir am besten an?
Wir brauchen den 5-Volt-Pin für Input.
Hier ist der Anschluss fürs Netzteil.
Dann brauchen wir die Kabel.
Ach, ganz wichtig, Leute.
Wisst ihr, wer fehlt?
Der wichtigste, der heimliche Star des Streams fehlt wieder.
Wer hat ihn erkannt?
Wer ist das?
Der Chain-Lore, der ist da.
Der Heißkleber, auch nicht.
Es fehlt eindeutig der Abisoliert-Champ.
Was sonst?
Korrekt, der fehlt.
Den brauchen wir nämlich wahrscheinlich für irgendwelche Kabel gleich.
Okay.
Lötkolben.
Und nein, Chet, nicht der USB-Lötkolben.
Der richtige Lötkolben.
Ich weiß nicht, warum der Chet so heiß ist, immer diesen hässlichen USB-Lötkolben zu sehen.
Also, ich mach das jetzt mal, damit der Chet sich freut.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wo er ist.
Leute.
Der ist weg.
Der USB-Lötkolben ist weg.
RIP.
Das war's, kein USB-Lötkolben.
Einfach weg.
Weiß nicht, wo er ist.
Na gut, da muss ich den gescheiten Lötkolben rausholen.
Nämlich...
Oh, das ist das Multimeter jetzt drauf.
Die Lötstation.
Ich muss mal überlegen, wie ich das hier am besten anordne, weil eigentlich ist hier ja nicht wirklich Platz.
Hm.
Das kann man... Ach doch, ich weiß, wie das geht.
Das muss man ja nicht wirklich sehen.
Ich stelle das hier einfach neben hin.
Vor den Raspberry Pi.
Mach an.
Das ist gerade ein wenig eng hier auf dem Tisch.
So.
Den machen wir hier hinten hin.
Man muss es ja nicht wirklich sehen.
Kommt weg.
Kommt auch weg.
So, jetzt muss ich mal kurz überlegen, wie wir das am besten machen.
Also wir brauchen den 5-Volt-Pin an den ESP.
Was? Einfach Offscreen löten die? Warum?
Warum 5 Volt?
Naja, weil das ein 5-Volt-Netzteil ist.
Also der ESP hat zwar 3,3 Volt, aber das Netzteil ist ja 5 Volt und ich will da den ESP übers Netzteil betreiben.
So.
Also im Endeffekt muss ich das hier jetzt dranlöten.
Hätte ich hier einen ordentlichen Header drauf, dann hätte ich das auch in den Header stecken können, habe ich aber nicht.
Ich gebe dir Header, Digga.
Deswegen nehmen wir hier einfach mal zwei Kabels.
Und schneiden uns das mal ab ein Stück.
Das ist ja eher, sagen wir mal, temporär.
Gucken, kann man immer noch abmachen.
Wobei, wahrscheinlich behalte ich das sogar so.
Machen wir hier mal ein paar Kabels.
Am Ende kommt das eben in die Box.
Gucken, dass das ungefähr gleich lang ist.
Wunderbar.
So, schon ein bisschen her.
Mal überlegen, wie ich das letzte Mal angeschlossen habe.
Also, ähm.
Dings, dann brauchen wir hier.
Das muss hier rein.
Das stecken wir dann wahrscheinlich hier rein.
Ne, das hier.
Ne, das, ich weiß nicht, Schwachsinn, was ich erzählt habe.
Das, das machen wir hier dran.
Das kommt hier dran.
So.
Das hätte ich gar nicht gebraucht.
Das machen wir hier dran.
Und für den, ähm, für den Controller greifen wir das hier vorn ab.
Das ist viel einfacher.
Ja.
Da kann ich das nämlich auch einfach mit paar Jumperkabeln dranstecken.
Und gut ist.
Das ist, das ist eigentlich viel sinniger.
So.
Die Sache ist jetzt nur die.
Ich vermute mal, das hier ist plus.
Mit dem roten.
Und das andere ist minus.
Aber ich traue den Chinesen nicht, wenn die sowas bauen.
Deswegen würde ich sagen, ich hole mal gleich das Multimeter und messe das mal.
Bin mal da, bin mal da nicht sicher.
Chat was sagt ihr?
China-Chinesen trauen oder nachmessen?
Ground ist das gleiche, ja ja.
Mach ich schon.
Nachmessen.
Gut, das ist wahrscheinlich echt besser.
Trust them.
So, wir machen das hier mal ein bisschen kürzer.
Die China-Beschriftung ist sus.
Ja, das ist, das ist wohl wahr.
So.
Isolieren wir das mal ein Stückchen ab.
Das Ding ist echt gut hier.
Kost, kostet irgendwie nur.
Ich kriege dafür kein Geld, by the way.
Er kostet glaube ich nur 20 Euro auf Amazon.
Das ist halt zum abisolieren wirklich pock.
Guck mal hier.
Einfach, hallo.
Kamera, please.
Easy abisoliert.
Poggers.
Richtiger.
Abisoliert-Champ.
So.
Da haben wir das Kabel, also jetzt messen wir das mal kurz nach mit dem Multimeter, ob
das passt.
Ah, ich hab die, ich hab die falschen Dinger dran.
Ich brauch hier die Klemmen.
Machen wir mal raus.
Wo ist die andere?
Wo ist das?
Ach hier.
So, haben wir mal die Klemmen dran.
Also das ist jetzt das falsche.
Machen wir den mal ab.
Ich muss das mal ein bisschen ordentlicher weg machen, weil ich brauch das vielleicht
nachher und dann find ich wieder nix.
So und jetzt machen wir den Kram hier dran.
So, schauen wir mal.
Also vermutlich, vermutlich ist das hier plus.
Wie macht man das jetzt eigentlich gescheit?
Big, Big Brain.
Ähm, Elektrostells-Chat.
Wie macht man das jetzt eigentlich?
Auf was muss ich das jetzt schalten?
Also ich mein, auf Volt, Voltage-Messung bringt der wahrscheinlich nix.
Die Jodentester, was ist das davon?
Durchgang, jaja, aber welche, was ist das?
Was ist das?
Hier, Big Brain, der Chat, Massive, Massive Prime Subs müssen jetzt zeigen, was wir gebracht
haben.
Unter oben, das da?
Ne, das ist Frequenz.
Ach das hier.
Ne, das ist auch Frequenz, das ist was anderes.
Die Jodentest, Dreieck mit Strich an der großen Seite.
Was?
Dreieck?
Du meinst hier?
Das, das da?
Das da?
Ja?
Ok, Poggers, auf gehts.
So, ist das jetzt gut?
Oder schlecht?
Aber jetzt weiß ich doch nicht, was Plus und Minus ist.
Jetzt weiß ich doch nicht, was Plus und Minus ist dadurch, oder?
Doch, keine Ahnung.
Tausch mal rotes und schwarz?
Hä, Quatsch.
Ach so meinste?
Ich glaube, das funktioniert so nicht.
Keine Ahnung, ob der das kann.
So nicht ausprobiert.
Es ändert sich ja noch nicht mal was in die andere Richtung.
Ok Chat, das hat so schon mal nicht funktioniert.
Das hat so schon mal nicht funktioniert.
Halte mal das Kabel zusammen und schau, ob es piept.
Ok, Sack.
Achtung.
Ja.
Es piept.
Piept.
Das, das funktioniert.
Wir vertrauen, wir sind ja noch nie enttäuscht worden von den Chinesen.
Wir vertrauen der China Beschriftung.
Die wird schon passen.
Die haben uns noch nie im Stich gelassen.
China Produkte waren immer 100%.
Ich wusste, dass jetzt einer das Smoke Video postet.
Ja.
Da habe ich 20 Euro Controller gegrillt wegen Chinaspannungswandler.
Ok, also.
Übrigens keine Bedenken, dass es hier gerade so rumgeflogen ist.
Da löst Coins noch gar nicht an.
Aber jetzt ist er gleich an.
Wenn ich es entknotet habe.
Weil das so überhaupt nicht funktioniert.
So.
Gut.
Stegger.
Rein.
Es heizt.
Nicht.
Habe ich es ausgemacht?
Jetzt.
Es heizt.
Ok.
Dann löten wir das einfach mal dran.
Bitte fang an zu rauchen.
Der Chat.
Die Daub, das sind wieder richtig, richtig strong heute.
Der Löt-Coin war relativ teuer.
Hä?
Wie kommt?
Ja, ja.
War es.
Das ist eine Erser.
Sag mal hier.
Eine Erser Lötstation.
Eine Erser.
Das habe ich mir mal gegönnt, weil ich doch relativ viel löte in letzter Zeit.
Eine Erser Icon Nano.
Das kostet, glaube ich, so 120 Euro oder so.
Bei Amazon gucken.
Wir könnten jetzt ja.
Oh Leute, ich muss jetzt was ausprobieren.
Das habe ich mir vor einer Weile gekauft.
Das habe ich noch nicht für nichts, noch nie ausprobiert.
Das müssen wir jetzt machen.
Wo ist das Ding?
Hier, guckt mal.
Ich habe mir so ein Ding mal gekauft.
Hatte schon wieder Staub angesetzt.
Weil ich es einfach auf dem Basteltisch stehen hatte.
Und nie verwendet.
Guck mal.
Hatte ich mir vor einer Weile mal gekauft, weil es immer so eklig ist, die Sachen festzuhalten.
Das testen wir jetzt mal aus.
Das testen wir jetzt.
Bin ich mal gespannt, ob das was taugt.
Zack.
Hier.
Guck mal.
Das ist nicht nur eine dritte Hand.
Das ist eine dritte, vierte, fünfte und sechste Hand.
So.
Guck mal, das ist magnetisch.
Und da kann man jetzt, man kann beispielsweise alle abmachen, weil man nur eins braucht.
Und da kann man jetzt hier das Ding nehmen und da reinklemmen.
Und dann hat man keine Probleme mehr, den Kram irgendwie so zu platzieren.
Ach so, ihr seht es gar nicht.
Moment.
Siehste, easy gedreht.
Und da hat man gar kein Problem mehr, den Kram so zu platzieren, dass man was sieht.
Haben meine Hände nur ein Finger?
Ja.
Wie, ist das jetzt Fingershaming oder was?
Ist das ein Problem, wenn ich nur ein Finger hab?
So.
Drehen wir das mal ein bisschen rum.
Excellent.
Tja.
Dann, dann löten wir es nochmal einfach dran.
Ach so, ich brauch das Lötze noch, das ist irgendwo hier unten.
Deine Finger haben nur eine Hand.
Ja.
Sieht bei meinem Fuß ähnlich aus.
Zack.
So.
Wir machen erst mal, bevor wir hier anfangen.
Das ist cool, jetzt sehe ich auch was.
Das ist richtig nice.
Erkennt ihr auch?
Oh fuck.
Ich hoffe ihr erkennt auch was.
So.
Richtig, richtig professional mittlerweile, ja.
So, wir machen das jetzt.
Jetzt sehe ich was.
Das ist richtig, richtig nice, wenn man, wenn man sieht, was man macht.
Jetzt ist nur noch das Kabel hier doof eingedeckt.
Okay.
Machen wir es einfach mal heiß und machen wir ein bisschen Lötzend drüber.
So.
Excellent.
Irgendwie habe ich gerade ein bisschen, irgendwas heißes abgekriegt.
So, ein bisschen Lötzend dran.
Machen wir an beides, an beide Seiten ein bisschen Lötzend dran.
Das sollten wir jetzt, das sollten wir jetzt von der anderen Seite machen.
Gucken, gucken, ob das damit, das Ding, das Ding ist nice.
Das gefällt mir.
Das Ding gefällt mir.
Okay, jetzt kann man es einfach drehen.
Das richtig pockt das Teil.
So, machen wir unten ein bisschen.
Na, jetzt ist, jetzt ist natürlich schön, schön das Ringlight im Weg.
So.
Gut.
Jetzt haben wir hier schön ein bisschen Lötzend dran gemacht.
Jetzt würde ich sagen, machen wir da mal die Kabel dran.
Also, was brauchen wir denn hier?
Also, unsere Vermutung ist ja, das ist Plus und das ist Minus.
So, und wenn mich nicht alles täuscht, dann ist das in der Mitte Plus und das Außen Minus.
Bei diesem Stecker.
So, dann machen wir das mal dran.
Sieht man was?
Ne, das ist gerade aus dem Bild.
Das ist dumm.
So.
Dann machen wir das mal.
Vielleicht sollte ich vorher hier noch ein bisschen.
Das funzt richtig gut, wenn man was sieht.
Wer hätte das gedacht?
Weil man was erkennen kann, hat seine Vorteile.
Ich habe es ein bisschen, bisschen weit.
Ich habe es ein bisschen weit abisoliert.
Das muss ich auf jeden Fall noch mal machen.
Das ist, das ist zu, zu weit.
Das gibt mir einen Kurzschluss im Zweifelsfall.
Muss ich noch mal schnell abschnippeln.
Besten hier mit.
Ich meine, man könnte auch einen Schrumpfschlauch drüber machen, aber das ist jetzt,
das ist ja temporär zum Ausprobieren.
Aber ich will trotzdem keinen Kurzschluss fabrizieren.
Muss nicht sein.
So, so ist gut.
Gut, also noch mal.
Moment, doch ja, richtig, richtig.
Das ist nicht richtig heiß, jetzt, jetzt.
Oh fuck, es war zu heiß.
What the hell?
Habe ich das zu heiß gestellt?
Das braucht ewig 350 Grad, ist doch eigentlich in Ordnung.
Das ist jetzt richtig schön fest.
Das ist nice.
Das gefällt mir.
Bei Crown mache ich eine Öse in der Leitung.
Zack.
Ich muss kalisen.
Die Öse in der Leitung dann durchstecken und zudrücken.
Ist bomben sicher.
Exzellent.
Es ist jetzt ja eigentlich nur zum Ausprobieren, ob das funktioniert,
weil ich muss das ja nachher in die Box einbauen und sowas.
So, rumdrehen.
Sodass man irgendwas sieht.
Und jetzt löten wir das hier oben dran.
Man ist jetzt einfach so, da kann überhaupt nichts passieren.
Poggers, passt.
Bomben sicher.
Das ist wirklich ordentlich fest.
Kann man sich nicht beschweren.
China-Chinesen, also passt das.
Hier ist rot, hier ist nicht rot.
Da ist Minus, da ist Plus.
Sollte passen.
Okay.
Jetzt kommt es an, wenn es jetzt raucht, habe ich es verkackt.
Dann hätte ich aber doch besser nachmessen sollen
und China-Chinesen nicht vertrauen.
Aber nachher ist man ja immer schlauer.
Schauen wir mal.
Lötstation können wir glaube ich erstmal kurz ausschalten.
Aufwickeln.
Aus dem Weg machen.
Gut.
Also.
Ich werde jetzt mal kurz das Netzteil da dran anschließen,
aber dann sieht man noch nichts.
Wobei, ne.
Wir machen gleich den Controller dran.
Also was brauchen wir dafür?
Wir brauchen noch drei Jumperkabel würde ich sagen.
Jetzt übergangsweise zum Testen.
Jetzt ist mir sogar noch der Deckel von der Box runtergefallen.
Okay.
Ja.
Die nehmen wir jetzt.
Perfekt.
Also.
Vielleicht löte ich doch einen Header dran.
Vielleicht, vielleicht.
Ich glaube ich löte einen Header dran.
Ich gebe dir Header.
Ich glaube ich mache den Header dran.
Wir brauchen ja nur die Seite.
Man kann ja sogar den Pin umstellen jetzt.
Ich löte nur die Seite dran.
Das ist einfach praktischer.
Hier.
Den da.
Das ist einfach praktischer wenn da ein Header dran ist.
Also wie gesagt ich habe.
Ich habe einen 10 Ampere 5 Volt Netzteil.
Aber so viel braucht das nicht.
Das sind 5 Volt LEDs.
Das sind aber nur 50 Stück auf 5 Meter.
Also sprich.
Das braucht maximal 15 Watt. Also 5 Volt 3 Ampere wenn es hoch kommt.
Ich mache den Lötkolben nochmal an.
Ich glaube da brauchen wir jetzt keinen.
Kein extra Halterungs Ding für.
Was hast du mit deinem Xiaomi Thermometer vor?
Naja.
Luftfeuchtigkeit Temperatur abfragen.
Wir flashen das dann gleich noch hier nach.
Wenn das mit den LEDs funktioniert.
Moment.
Zack zack.
Doch.
Doch Leute.
Ich mache.
Nee vorbei.
Das ist doof.
Jetzt sehe ich wieder nichts gescheit.
Weil das Keylight im Weg ist.
Nee.
Nicht Keylight.
Ring.
Ringlight heißt es ja.
Mach ich das garantiert mega.
Das ist dumm wenn man nichts sieht.
Das hat echt seine Nachteile.
So guckt mal wie wahnsinnig gerade das jetzt ist.
Das muss ich doch mal machen.
Deswegen ist immer sinnvoll man lötet erst eins fest.
Weil dann kann man es einfach dran halten.
Wenn man das Kabel hier nicht so doof liegen hat.
Das nochmal aufmachen.
Gerade schieben.
Und wieder loslassen.
Jetzt ist es halbwegs gerade.
Guckt.
Hier sieht man es doch noch.
Weil hier sehe ich besser.
5 Volt.
Ground.
Mehr muss ich eigentlich gar nicht anlöten.
Das reicht schon.
Wir haben jetzt 5 Volt dran.
5 Volt.
Ground.
Und D4.
Mehr brauchen wir nicht.
Guckt.
5 Volt.
Ground.
D4.
Das ist alles was wir brauchen für die LED.
Ja super Kamera.
Come on.
Gut.
Ich lasse es jetzt einfach so.
Da kriege ich es im Zweifelsfall auch wieder einfacher ab.
Falls ich das doch nicht als Hedder dran haben will.
Gut.
Dann stelle ich den Lötkolben kurz weg.
Als es aus dem Weg ist.
Die noch irgendwie verbrenne oder so.
So dann nehmen wir mal die Jumperkabels.
Und zwar.
Dann nehmen wir das rote machen wir für 5 Volt.
Das braune nehmen wir für Ground.
Und das grüne nehmen wir für Data.
Ich lese den Chat gleich noch mal.
Kannst du die Lildschalen mal kurz zeigen?
Ja.
Die sind eigentlich relativ ordentlich.
Moment.
Geht man nicht gescheit.
Wartet mal.
Kamera.
Come on.
Es könnte ein bisschen mehr Lötzinn sein.
Aber das passt schon.
Das ist schon in Ordnung.
Also für das das ich es halb gesehen habe.
Ist ok.
Passt.
So und jetzt stopseln wir das mal an die LEDs hier dran.
Also hier ist angeschlossen.
Also plus 5 ist der hier.
Minus ist der hier.
Was ist das?
Guck mal das Kabel an.
Da hängt noch ein bisschen Schmodder vom letzten Mal dran.
Dann hält es auch besser.
Passt das überhaupt rein?
Passt das überhaupt rein so?
Ne.
Ich habe schon ein anderes Kabel.
Ja weiß weiß perfekt.
Also Ground.
Jetzt weiß.
Da hängt ja auch was dran.
Aber geht so.
Ground und Data ist das grüne.
Na super.
Jetzt habe ich es abgeknickt.
Perfekt.
Weil da so viel Schmodder dran hängt.
Ok.
So das sollte jetzt von der Idee her funktionieren.
Also wenn jetzt alles funktioniert schließe ich da jetzt das Netzteil an.
Mal gucken, dass hier hinten nichts zusammen hängt.
Nee passt.
Es kann eigentlich nichts passieren.
Also wenn das stimmt.
Dass das rote plus 5 Volt ist.
Das weiße Ground ist.
Ja.
Dann sollte das jetzt einfach funktionieren.
Wir vertrauen den Chinesen einfach mal.
Data ist muss man gucken D4.
Ground.
Also von der Idee her ist das alles.
Komplett korrekt richtig angeschlossen.
Dann testen wir doch mal.
Klippen für den Smoke.
Prediction.
Wollen wir Predictions machen?
Was machen wir für eine Prediction?
Geht geht nicht ist eine dofe Prediction.
Weil geht geht nicht könnte auch davon abhängen.
Dass ich in WLED Mist eingestellt habe.
Wir machen Prediction Rauch oder kein Rauch.
Da kann ich mir noch mal was zu trinken einschenken.
Rauch kein Rauch.
Oder wir machen wir machen Prediction kaputt.
Mach ich es kaputt.
Jetzt beim einstecken.
100 auf Rauch.
Muss man nichts mit Widerständen und so machen?
Nö an der Stelle nicht.
Brauchst keine Kondensatoren.
Brauchst keine Widerstände.
Das braucht 5 Volt.
Die LEDs brauchen 5 Volt.
Das hat einen Spannungswandler von 5 auf 3,3 Volt.
Also eigentlich brauchst du da nichts.
Haben wir eine Prediction laufen?
Wenn nicht mache ich die schnell.
Hier Moment Prediction.
Prediction.
Vorhersage starten.
Ergebnis ja Ergebnis nein.
Schauen wir mal.
Mal gucken was der Chat prediktet.
100.000 auf nein.
The fuck.
Hat einer zu viele Punkte oder was?
300.000.
Das wird bestimmt über Bots gesammelt.
Okay.
Der weit überwiegende Teil sagt nein.
Passt alles.
Okay.
Dann wollen wir mal Netzteil.
Noch mal kurz gucken ob das auch das richtige Netzteil ist.
Also Chat daran kann es nicht liegen.
5 Volt 10 Ampere.
Das ist das ausschlaggebende.
10 Ampere kriegen wir garantiert nicht durch.
Dann brennt es mir durch den Tisch.
Okay.
Strom ist drin.
Netzteil ist hier.
Okay.
Der Moment der Wahrheit.
Lass mich noch mal schnell hier hinten gucken.
Passt alles.
Es funzt einfach.
Es geht einfach.
Einfach.
Instant am Gehen.
Dazu kann ich nur sagen.
Ich wusste sofort.
So.
Wir haben kurz das Licht aus.
Als ich heute zur Abwechslung mal mein Ring light übers WLAN steuern darf.
Warum ist das im Arsch?
Warum ist die WLAN Steuerung vom Ring light im Arsch?
Was soll das?
Warum kackt das Ring light ab?
Das Ring light geht kaputt wenn ich es ausschalte.
Das ist kaputt.
Man muss das fünfmal machen.
Das ist ja witzig.
Jetzt steht das Ring light auf 5% oder so.
Jetzt konnte ich es ausschalten.
Okay.
Ihr seht es funktioniert.
Jetzt können wir das Ganze auch mal steuern.
Man erkennt nicht so viel, weil das noch ein Ring ist.
Back.
Jetzt kann man schöne Dinge machen wie z.B.
Brightness ist voller Pulle.
Man kann die Brightness regeln.
Da wird es weniger.
Brightness hoch machen.
Eigentlich müsste das weiß sein.
Das weiß ist nicht sonderlich schönes weiß.
Das ist doch nicht orange.
Die Brightness ist ganz unten.
Jetzt kann man so schöne Sachen machen wie z.B.
Effekte.
Was ich persönlich mag ist Fire 2012.
Man erkennt es im Endeffekt.
Weil es eine Spule ist.
Das gibt es auch als App.
Wir können testen, ob die Farben funktionieren.
Rot.
Red.
Blau.
Was habe ich denn?
Rot, blau, grün.
Sieht auch gut aus.
Die Ansteuerung ist auf jeden Fall korrekt.
Kann man nichts sagen.
Ich würde vorschlagen, ich mache mal kurz das Ringleit wieder an.
Kann man das auch in eine HA etikeln?
Ja, mega easy.
Das zeige ich euch gleich.
Ich mache mal kurz das Ringleit wieder an.
Alter, ich will das Ringleit auf 100% wieder stellen.
Warum ist die WLAN-Steuerung von dem Ringleit so broken?
Das verstehe ich nicht.
Ich hatte das 5 Mal an oder so.
Kann ja nicht sein.
Das funktioniert nur alle 5 Mal klicken.
Das ist doch eigentlich der Witz, oder?
Ich kann meinen Ringleit nicht auf 100% mehr stellen.
Jetzt hat es funktioniert.
Das ist ja broken.
Verstehe ich nicht.
Das ist nicht für einen PC.
Der Controller ist ja auch das Ding hier.
Das ist ja der Controller.
Es gibt Leute, die kommen auf die glorreiche Idee
und schließen die LEDs an den Controller an.
Das funktioniert ja theoretisch.
Ich könnte ja per USB den Controller anschließen
und dann hier über das 5 Volt die LEDs.
Das Problem ist nur, dass der Controller nicht dafür ausgelegt ist,
bis zu 3 Ampere über die Pins zu machen.
Ich glaube, 500 mA ist das Maximum, was man machen darf.
Es ist auf jeden Fall keine sinnvolle Idee.
Und dann musst du jedes Mal ein Netzteil davor.
Ja klar.
Was denn sonst?
Irgendwie muss da Strom herkommen.
Und ob ich da jetzt einen USB-Netzteil nehme
oder einen 5 Volt-Netzteil, macht ja keinen Unterschied,
weil ein USB-Netzteil ist auch ein normales 5 Volt-Netzteil.
Was empfiehlst du für die Stromversorgung,
wenn man keinen Bock auf Netzteile löten hat?
Ähm...
Du musst doch gar keinen Netzteil löten.
Ach so, du meinst hier unten...
Wieso ist doch...
Nee, nee, also...
Also wie gesagt, das Netzteil ist viel zu fett.
Du kannst doch so ein ganz normales Stecker-Netzteil nehmen,
was ist quasi so ein kleines...
Was denn die Steckdose?
Und machst ohne extra Zeug, ja.
Also mehr als den 5 Volt-10 Ampere-Netzteil
wirst du fast nirgendwo kriegen.
Also viel mehr...
Weiß nicht, ob sie viel mehr herstellen dafür normalerweise.
Das ist eigentlich überhaupt kein Ding.
Du mein, du brauchst ja eine Stromversorgung.
Andere Möglichkeiten hast du ja im Endeffekt nicht.
Ähm, ja, ich versuche euch jetzt mal die Integration zu zeigen
in Home Assistant.
Es kann aber sein, dass das nicht funktioniert,
weil ich ja nicht direkt rankomme.
Ich bin ja über den Access Point.
Und den Access Point, der nattet,
aus irgendwelchen Gründen habe ich festgestellt,
was ziemlich sackt.
Da muss ich Port-Weiterleitung machen.
Da habe ich jetzt keinen Bock drauf.
Also was man machen kann, ist, man kann in Home Assistant gehen.
Zack.
Configuration.
Integrations.
Add Integration.
Und dann gibt es hier unten WLED.
WLED.
Und da muss man jetzt die IP eingeben,
und das funktioniert nicht.
Weil ich komme nicht direkt an...
Ich komme nicht hier dran vom Home Assistant.
Der Home Assistant ist bei mir lokal eine VM,
und das hier ist über den Access Point erreichbar.
Kann man im Home Assistant Static Routes setzen?
Wenn das funktioniert, dann klappt das.
Ich mache mal kurz das Kamerabild weg.
Home Assistant Static Routes.
Geht das?
Die Idee bin ich noch nie gegangen,
noch nie gekommen.
Was zum...
Ist das hier die Anleitung dafür oder was?
What?
Are you serious?
Was?
Ich muss, ich editier doch kein Yammel-Config für...
Was zum...
Was machen die da?
Set IP for 4 Routes.
Okay, probieren wir mal aus.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
No.
Was habe ich für ein Passwort zum Einloggen?
Was habe ich da genommen?
Zeig mal her.
Supervisor, SSH Addon, Configuration.
Ah, Passwort.
Cute Chat 1, 2, 3.
Alles klar.
So, und was soll ich jetzt machen?
Das habe ich noch nie gemacht.
N, N, NMCLI.
Kacke.
Das ist, wenn man...
Das ist die Sache so krass verschlimmbessert.
Einfach adden und gut ist.
So, und wie funktioniert das jetzt?
NMCLI.
Set IP Route.
Leute, ich habe legit keine Ahnung, wie das...
Set.
Ich habe legit keine Ahnung, wie das hier funktioniert.
Static Routes zu setzen.
Ich meine ping kann ich davon hier logischerweise nicht.
Da fehlt die Route.
Route add geht ja hier so wahrscheinlich nicht.
Das gilt für den Container.
Wie benutzt man den Kram noch jetzt?
NMCLI Device Show.
Das ist da nicht noob freundlich.
Nimm doch das NAT DACP.
Ja, da muss ich...
Ich glaube, das ist jetzt einfacher.
Edit Parameters on Card.
NMCLI Con-Edit.
Das ENP.
Das da.
Null, Alter.
Wenn das jetzt funktioniert, dann...
Wäre ich mich kaputt.
Natürlich nicht.
Weil?
Warum nicht?
Was soll ich?
General Connection.
Ach, das da.
Home Assistant, die Volllos.
Na, die Netzwerkkarte einfach anzugeben, das wäre ja zu einfach gewesen.
Okay.
Und jetzt?
Pains Champion.
Set.
Ah, das Auto.
Oh, das ist einfach nicht das Auto complete.
Hier oben gucken.
Seht ihr hier Root?
Ey, das ist mir zu dumm.
Das ist mir zu dumm.
Wer hat sich denn den Schrott ausgetacht?
Wo käme ich jetzt hier den Gateway überhaupt an?
Ach, hier.
Okay.
Also Set, Set IP, Roots.
So.
So, das heißt Set IP, Roots, das Slash 84.
Und dann einfach den Gateway hinten dran.
Piss dich, Aldo.
Ich hab das genauso gemacht, wie ihr das wollt.
Ups, ich hab Dings mit kopiert.
Ah ja, okay.
Und jetzt Save.
Print.
Print IPv4.
Ah ja, Obvious, Obvious.
Alles klar, alles klar.
Apply, Save, Persistent.
Okay.
Reboot?
Was?
Ich muss den Reboot...
Ah, Reboot.
Wie Reboot man den Kram überhaupt?
NMCL, ja, übers Webinterface.
Okay, bin immer gespannt, ob das funktioniert.
Dann hier Reboot.
Meine Güte, ey.
Das glaube ich nicht, dass es das getan hätte, den Networkmanager zu restarten.
Das SSH ist ein Docker-Container, der eigentlich da normalerweise nichts machen darf.
System, System, Restart, Reboot Host.
Okay, Reboot oder Mist jetzt?
Ja.
Jetzt bin ich ja mal gespannt, ob das jetzt funktioniert hat mit der Route, die ich gesetzt hab.
Ich tippe ja mal drauf, eher nicht.
Aber schauen wir mal.
HA geprickt?
Ja, das ist nicht schlimm, das ist mein Test-Home-Assistent.
Da kann ich pricken, was ich will.
Wer wird da für nichts verwendet?
So, genug.
Paints Champinged.
Jetzt starte mal.
Oh, wenn er schon kein NTP abrufen kann, stimmt da irgendwas nicht.
Das ist schlecht, wenn er schon kein NTP abrufen kann.
Ah, oder?
Oder doch?
Wie viele ich bestellt hab?
Fünf Stück.
Machen wir dann gleich noch.
So, SSH, Qt, Chat, eins, zwei, drei.
Achtung, Ping.
Das funktioniert.
Hat geklappt.
Easy.
Ja, dann.
Also, kann ich euch jetzt zeigen, also Configuration, Integration, Add, WLED, zack.
WLED hinzufügen.
Das ist die IP.
Ach so, was man vielleicht vorher machen sollte ist, also was sich anbietet.
Man geht in seinen DHCP.
Man geht in seinen DHCP, sucht sich die IP raus.
Und sagt Make Static.
Das ist immer die gleiche.
Am besten ist noch ein Kommentar, irgendwie WLED, Weihnachtsbaum oder so.
So, dann weiß man nämlich, was das ist.
Alles klar, Configuration.
Ach, Homes ist bestimmt noch nicht richtig gestartet.
Das braucht immer ein bisschen, bis sich's eingeklickt hat wieder.
New Device is discovered.
Ha, nope.
Integrations, Add, WLED.
Host, der da, Submit.
Bam, finish.
Da ist es, WLED, One Device.
Wunderbar.
Hat funktioniert.
So, und jetzt kann ich mir hier einen Schalter machen für meine Lichterkette.
Oder wir können jetzt, wir können den Schalter hier, wir machen den Schalter hier drin.
Gehen wir mal davon aus, das wäre Ambilight.
Ambilight für den Fernseher zum Beispiel jetzt oder irgendwas.
Nein, nicht wirklich Ambilight.
Irgendwie Beleuchtung, RGB-Beleuchtung fürs Wohnzimmer.
Hinzufügen.
Neuer Switch.
WLED.
Und Name.
Ist ich.
Licht.
So, zack.
Und schon kann ich über meinen Home Assistant den Kram steuern.
Guck.
Aus.
An.
Und.
Long press.
Komplette Einstellung für RGB.
Was natürlich sehr nice ist.
So.
Man kann das auch anders adden.
Man kann auch sagen.
Anstatt so, es gibt glaube ich ein extra Light Entity kann man machen.
Also anstatt das da.
Es gibt glaube ich, es gibt glaube ich Light.
Ah ne, hat er schon.
Er hat schon das Richtige genommen.
Es war gar kein Button.
Na gut.
Name.
Licht.
Genau.
Hä?
Ich glaube, ich habe ihn verwirrt, dass ich es jetzt doppelt geadded habe.
Guck mal.
Null.
Muss niesen, aber.
Funktioniert nicht.
Ja guck, man kann hier sogar dimmen jetzt drüber.
Ja, ausschalten.
Anschalten.
Und RGB Settings.
Das Coole ist mit der WLED Integration.
Mit der WLED Integration.
Frage.
Oh die Prediction läuft noch.
Ah Sack.
Prediction.
Die Prediction ist relativ einfach zu lösen.
Ergebnis wählen.
Es ging nicht kaputt.
Nein.
Abschließen.
Ja.
Aber in der Praxis über ein paar.
Nein, ich habe einen Low Power x86 Intel.
Wo Home Assistant und alles drauf läuft.
Pi ist mir da nicht schnell genug gewesen.
Gerade das Neustarten dauert sonst Pains Champ lange.
Aber Raspberry Pi geht auch.
Raspberry Pi geht auch.
Aber dann würde ich den SSD reinmachen.
Pasip, danke für den Zap.
Man hat ja direkt Zugriff auf die Effekte in Home Assistant.
Also ich kann jetzt hier zum Beispiel sagen, keine Ahnung.
Twinkle Cat.
Und dann macht er das jetzt.
Was man jetzt nicht richtig erkennt.
Oder wie gesagt, mein persönlicher Lieblings Effekt.
Ist natürlich jetzt dumm.
Mein persönlicher Lieblings Effekt ist ja.
Ah ja.
2012.
So und wir machen jetzt mal schnell die Leisten ein bisschen auseinander.
Weil ich mir die LEDs machen gucken will.
Dazu machen wir mal den Strom raus.
Ich will jetzt mein Glück da nicht komplett herausfordern.
Nehme ich da jetzt gerade Rumpfinger.
Während das an ist.
Ich mache das mal kurz aus.
Ich will mir die Dinger mal angucken.
Man muss halt aufpassen, dass man es nicht kaputt macht.
Hier jetzt.
Ist das ein Pflaster?
Was die Chinesen?
Ne.
Oder?
Das fühlt sich an wie ein Pflaster.
Bestimmt aus einer chinesischen Corona Impfstation oder so.
War noch übrig.
Ne das ist Klebeband.
Das ist Klebeband.
Das ist gar kein Pflaster.
Was für LEDs sind das genau?
Vom Typ her das sind WS2812 glaube ich.
So schauen wir uns mal an wie das ausschaut.
Ach ja by the way.
Wir müssen also im Praxisbetrieb muss man wahrscheinlich Strom auf diese Seite auch
noch injecten.
Weil 5 Meter ist der Widerstand zu lang.
Die LEDs sehen am Ende nicht mehr gut aus.
Gehe ich jetzt einfach mal von aus.
Was aber kein Problem ist.
Das kann man hier einfach irgendwas ranstecken und dann geht das.
Ich könnte zum Beispiel auch das hier nehmen.
Was ich gegiftet bekommen habe davon.
So ich mache das mal kurz ausnahm.
Mal schauen wie das aussieht.
Ich glaube mir den muss man ein bisschen vorsichtiger sein.
Weil die sehen doch sehr gebrechlich aus.
Das klingt vielleicht auch nicht zu enge.
Moment what the fuck.
Hä?
Wait a minute.
War doch richtig was ich gemacht habe.
Muss einmal unten durch.
Hier haben wir die LEDs.
Also das müssten 5 Meter sein.
Schauen wir mal ob das ungefähr hinkommt.
5 Meter.
Ich muss das mal hochheben dass ich das aushängen kann.
Oh nee die sind so dumm aufgerollt.
Jetzt muss sie hier das durchmachen dass sie das runter.
Das ist ja dumm.
China Logik.
Ich mache es nicht komplett auseinander.
Leute das kriege ich da nicht mal aufgewickelt gescheint.
Wenn ich das jetzt komplett auseinander mache.
Aber nur mal um zu gucken ob die LEDs halbwegs passen.
Das muss man glaube ich eh dann einmal aushängen lassen.
Dass es auch die Schleifen und so rauskriegt.
So wir machen noch mal kurz an.
Ja seht ihr.
Der Strom reicht gar nicht mehr für die letzten LEDs.
Guckt.
Die letzten LEDs leuchten gar nicht mehr.
Die leuchten gar nicht mehr.
Das muss man auf jeden Fall hier hinten nochmal Strom injecten.
Dass das funktioniert.
Das würde ich übrigens generell empfehlen.
Also wenn man längere LED Strips hat immer vorne und hinten Strom dran machen.
Dann hat man das ganze Problem nicht.
Und man sieht auch dass das Gelb zunehmend orange wird.
Muss keine Autobatterie dran.
Autobatterie wäre das Ding direkt Schrott.
Ja gut.
Kunst sehr schön.
Also LED haben wir erfolgreich abgeschlossen.
Funktioniert auch relativ gut.
Hast du die LED Anzahl in WLED eingestellt?
Ja habe ich.
Das ist aber klar.
Also wie gesagt 5 Meter.
Also ich habe ja hier am Fenster auch was.
Da war das genauso.
Das musst du vorne und hinten injecten.
Das Problem ist ich kann das jetzt nicht so einfach gerade hier machen.
Weil da müsste ich noch was dran löten.
Weil ich habe hier schlicht und ergreifend keinen Anschluss gerade.
Um das zu machen.
Da müsste ich dann beispielsweise eine Klemme oder so nehmen.
Ja da müsste ich mal gucken.
Das überlege ich mir Offstream.
Das müssen wir nicht hier machen.
Man hat gesehen es funktioniert.
Und es funktioniert ehrlich gesagt ziemlich easy.
Also viel einfacher geht es nicht.
Was?
Nein so viel braucht das doch nicht.
Ihr wollt auch nicht dass es euer Haus einäschert.
Ach so.
Ach jetzt verstehe ich was du.
Jetzt verstehe ich es.
Ich habe es falsch gelesen.
Also wenn du einen 5 Meter LED Strip hast.
Was 18 Ampere benötigt.
Dann ist das höchstwahrscheinlich einer der was weiß ich 100 100 LEDs den Meter hat.
100 140 LEDs den Meter oder sowas.
Also er ist bestimmt schon ein bisschen besser bestückt.
Und du solltest auf jeden Fall vorne und hinten injecten.
Aber das hier ist egal.
Das hier ist egal.
Die Spannung ist das wichtige.
Wie viel wie viel der Netzwerk der Netzteil maximal liefern kann ist egal.
Also wichtig ist was.
Also du kannst auch einen 500 Ampere Netzteil nehmen.
Und es dran anschließen.
Das braucht trotzdem nur 18.
Aber du solltest nicht auf die Idee kommen 12 Volt Netzteil zu nehmen.
Weil dann ist Monka Smoke angesagt.
So wie machen wir jetzt weiter Leute.
Wir haben jetzt LEDs gemacht.
Wunderbar.
Dann würde ich sagen wir machen jetzt die Custom Firmware für das Thermometer.
Dann werde ich die LEDs mal kurz.
Wobei die kann ich hier liegen lassen.
Stört doch eigentlich gar nicht.
Das Netzteil mache ich mal weg.
Das brauchen wir hier wirklich nicht mehr.
Im Weg.
Löten müssen wir dafür auch nichts.
Kann ich auch weg stellen.
Ein bisschen Platz machen.
So.
Gut perfekt.
Also machen wir mit dem Ding weiter.
Nein das hat noch nicht funktioniert mit dem Thermometer.
Das ging doch nicht.
Das war doch broken.
Die haben wir doch kaputt gemacht.
Hier ich habe hier oben doch noch eins.
Guck mal.
Ja so eines von den kaputten.
Da ist nämlich das Problem.
Ihr werdet es gleich sehen.
Wo ist die wo ist die Batterie.
Das Problem bei denen waren die haben wir geflasht.
Und nachdem die geflasht waren.
Ist folgendes passiert.
Ich mache hier mal die Batterie rein.
Die sind einfach nicht mehr angegangen.
Keg Weight.
Richtig Keg Weight.
Massive Keg Weight HD.
War da angesagt.
Und es ist nicht die Batterie die im Arsch ist.
Das ist die Firmware.
Und es gibt jetzt eine neue Firmware Version.
Und das probieren wir jetzt mal aus.
Also.
Original.
Machen wir mal auf.
China Sachen sind da immer hartnäckig.
Wiederspenstig.
Äh ja.
Die kann man.
Also das ist nicht kaputt.
Der Display Controller ist nicht geht nicht.
Also wenn ich das jetzt neu flashe.
Dann geht es wieder.
Ich nehme aber ein neues.
Das alte kann man dann vielleicht entpricken gleich noch.
So hier ist es.
Das ist der Kleber für die Wand.
Hier ist die Batterie drin.
So wenn ich das jetzt rausziehe.
Dann geht es an mit der Originalfirma.
Nochmal so Recap für alle die nicht dabei waren warum man das macht.
Also.
Das Ding kommuniziert über Bluetooth Low Energy.
Normalerweise nur mit der offiziellen App auf dem Handy.
Man kann die Sache bestimmt irgendwie verbinden.
Und es gibt auch Custom.
Also.
Für so ESP Controller zum Beispiel.
Für ESP32.
Gibt es auch Firmware die das ausliest.
Diese Bluetooth Meldung und sowas.
Das funktioniert.
Ein großer Nachteil der offiziellen Firmware ist.
Erstens dass man es halt nur gescheit steuern kann.
Über die offizielle App.
Über die China App.
Das eigentliche Problem was ich habe ist.
Dass die Batterie.
Saumäßig schnell leer geht im Original Zustand.
Wie viel Reichweite haben die Dinger.
Boah das kann ich schlecht sagen.
Ich habe ich.
Ich habe Empfang hier.
Und ich habe drüben im Bad eins hängen.
Das ist keine Ahnung.
5 Meter oder so weg.
Also Luftlinie.
Aber siehe dann hin.
Dass ich eine Katze habe.
Ja.
Das andere Hand ist noch schlimmer.
Und wenn man die flasht.
Kann man einstellen.
Dass der.
Viel seltener.
Die Daten announced.
Über Bluetooth.
Normalerweise schickt dieses Ding.
Alle glaube alle 5 oder 15 Sekunden.
Die Daten über Luftfeuchtigkeit und Temperatur raus.
Was halt fail ist mal ganz im Ernst.
Wer braucht alle 15 Sekunden Update.
Wenn man das runter stellt.
Auf was weiß ich alle 2 Minuten.
Oder gar so vielleicht alle 5 Minuten.
Dann hält die Batterie anstatt.
Zum halben Jahr einfach 2 Jahre lang.
Also das vermute ich jetzt.
Weil ich habe meins ungefähr ein Jahr laufen jetzt.
Und es ist bei glaube.
Was ist ich.
93 Prozent oder so Batterie.
Also das ist auf jeden Fall deutlich besser.
Als mit der original Firmware.
So um das zu flashen.
Gibt es zwei Firmware.
Es gibt einmal.
Es gibt die Firmware.
Und es gibt.
Die Firmware.
Imi hatte ich die Thermometer geschickt.
Und der hat das auch direkt eingebaut.
Die Firmware.
Was echt nice ist.
Weil sie sind da echt auf Zack.
Aber die Firmware hat glaube ich.
Ein bisschen mehr Features.
Deswegen bin ich mir jetzt gar nicht so sicher.
Welche Firmware ich eigentlich verwenden soll.
Aber nachdem das hier ein Fork vom Original ist.
Würde ich die hier verwenden.
Bin ich mir aber nicht so ganz sicher.
Welche ich davon jetzt nehmen soll.
Hier der hat persistent storage geedit.
Gucken wir mal ob der andere das auch hat.
Der hat kein persistent storage.
Persistent storage wäre schon poggers.
Tja.
Welche Firmware nehmen wir denn?
Also dafür gibt es hier die custom firmware.
Die ich gezeigt habe.
Das ist der Grund warum ich mir das Thermometer überhaupt bestellt habe.
Weil ich wusste dass es custom firmware dafür gibt.
Münze entscheidet.
Ne.
Ich nehme erstmal die hier.
Und wenn es da irgendwie Probleme gibt.
Dann nehmen wir die andere.
Schauen wir mal.
Gut.
Go to over the air update page.
Ah Moment.
Das muss ich über Windows machen.
Weil das Ding Zugriff auf meinen Bluetooth braucht.
Du musst hier einen Pile.
Du musst es nicht über den Raspberry Pi machen.
So.
Bluetooth.
Ok.
Also wie wird geflasht.
Getting started.
Go over the air updater.
Ja.
Connect.
Bitte aktivieren Sie Bluetooth.
Der einzige Mal wo ich echt in Windows hier reingehe.
Bluetooth.
Chainschamp.
Ja.
Shield Dreamscreen.
Poggers.
Das brauchen wir jetzt.
Also halt.
Ok.
Also.
Dann mache ich das jetzt auf.
Ja ich weiß der Chat hat sich schon eingehackt über Bluetooth.
Alles klar.
Was sonst.
Ok.
Was.
Wie geht das weiter.
Du siehst.
1.6.
Sag da ich jetzt offiziell dass es unterstützt wird oder nicht.
Ah hier.
Und Autodetection Hardware Revisions.
Ok.
Nice.
Also man kann hier das richtige.
Das richtige Flash.
Also im Endeffekt gehe ich da hin.
Sag connect.
Warte bis es auftaucht.
Und.
Ah ja gut.
Connect.
Und jetzt hier.
Leute.
Haha.
Das ist der falsche.
Jebaited.
Hier.
Ich mache es jetzt erst an.
Da.
Massive Jebait.
Oh ne.
Ist ausgegangen.
Und jetzt warten wir bis wir es finden.
Hat jemand aufgepasst was der falsche war.
Hier drinnen.
Nicht dass ich jetzt wirklich das falsche nehmen.
ATC.
Ja stimmt.
Das heißt auch schon falsch.
Ja.
Also das heißt ja auch.
Schauen wir die custom firmware.
Da ist er.
Koppeln.
Connecting.
Ja.
Connected.
Alles klar.
Also man sieht es funktioniert noch alles.
Ok.
Do activation.
Da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
Das muss man machen.
Do activation.
Und jetzt.
Button Decrypt Key Process Now You Can Press Custom Firmware Button.
Custom Firmware Version 3.3.
Temperaturen stimmen auch überein.
Hier 4,5 und 56%.
Jawoll.
Custom Firmware Version 3.3.
Und jetzt sollte das eigentlich flashen.
Und hier haben wir es das letzte Mal kaputt gemacht.
Weil nach dem Flash ging das Display nicht mehr.
Werden wir jetzt sehen ob alles funktioniert.
Macht der jetzt was?
Ach hier.
Start.
Lull.
DFU.
DFU macht er.
So jetzt wird geflashed.
Bin mal gespannt ob es jetzt funktioniert.
Großer Pause Champ Moment.
Was Raspberry Pi 4s kriegt man gerade nicht.
Geh mal nicht auf zack Google.
Was ist da alles da?
Was gibt es da noch?
Compute Model.
Amazon.
Er flasht noch.
3,4.
Oh.
Alter.
Jetzt war es ja mal gut hier.
7 Wochen.
Was ist denn passiert?
Habe ich irgendwas verpasst?
Was kostet der mit 8G normalerweise?
Keine Ahnung.
Weiß nicht aus dem Kopf.
Okay also er hat fertig geflashed.
Press connect.
Gekoppelt okay.
Weiß ich aus dem Kopf nicht was er normalerweise kostet.
Aber der 8er war schon standardmäßig übertrieben.
Was ist jetzt?
Warum ist es disconnected wieder?
Geht das Display noch?
Okay das Display geht noch Leute.
Also wir sind schon mal weiter als das letzte Mal.
Wo ist jetzt das Problem?
Reconnect.
Einer ist nicht prickt.
Dadurch die sind ja nie richtig prickt gewesen.
Das einzige war das Display funktioniert nicht.
Du hast den falschen connected.
Nee ich habe nicht den falschen connected.
Falsche Blut Quatsch.
Hä?
Nein.
Gebaited.
Connect.
Gekoppelt das kann nur der sein.
Jaja das ist der richtige.
Gat connect.
Ja was denn jetzt?
Connected.
Aha da sind wir.
Funktioniert.
Version 1.6.
Das ist das richtige.
So und jetzt kann man da Sachen dran einstellen.
Und das Display funktioniert auch noch.
Das ist schon mal schön.
Aber wir können jetzt zum Beispiel mal testen.
Battery zum Beispiel kann man jetzt anzeigen lassen.
Battery.
Was passiert eigentlich wenn ich auf Show klicke?
Show?
Hast du jetzt irgendwas getan?
Also richtig beautiful UI ja.
Ach nee hier muss man Show Bud machen.
Get Time.
Nee Time brauchen wir nicht.
Time ist.
Komm mal hier.
Battery.
Bäm.
Hab das gesehen.
Das funktioniert.
Man kann die Uhrzeit anzeigen lassen.
Das würde ich aber nicht empfehlen die Uhrzeit anzeigen zu lassen.
Weil die Uhrzeit ist relativ schnell ungenau.
Home Assistant 11 ist raus.
Ein Moment.
Was?
Home Assistant Blog.
Lesen wir uns gleich mal durch was es für Neuigkeiten gibt.
Ah ja ist eben gerade das.
Das gucken wir uns gleich noch zusammen an.
Ok.
Also Battery funktioniert.
Also wir sehen schon mal die Sachen gehen jetzt im Vergleich zum letzten Mal.
Also was tun wir an?
Und Smiley wollen wir überhaupt haben?
Ja Standard ist doch ok.
Smiley.
Ja.
Ok was kann man sonst noch einstellen?
Also jetzt wird es wichtig.
Temperature Offset brauchen wir nicht.
Advertising Typ.
Muss man einstellen.
Man kann es.
Es gibt verschiedene Sachen.
Wenn man die offizielle App verwenden will muss man das einstellen.
Alles andere ist egal.
Ich lasse es auf Custom weil ich lese das eben mit meinem ESP aus.
Und da stört mich das nicht weiter.
Custom.
So und das hier ist jetzt das wo man richtig viel Batterie sparen kann.
Der Standard Advertising Intervall ist alle 2500 Millisekunden.
Also das sind alle 2,5 Sekunden.
Das ist massiv.
Das ist brutal viel.
Kein Wunder dass die Batterie so schnell leer geht.
Das kann man ohne Probleme mal auf eine Minute stellen.
Oder ehrlich gesagt man kann das auch auf zwei Minuten stellen.
Oder noch mehr.
Ach ne hier ist der Measure Intervall.
Ich habe Mist erzählt.
Das ist das was er Advertised.
Und der Measure Intervall ist viermal Advertising Intervall.
Das heißt wenn ich den hier auf 60 Stelle.
Auf 60 Sekunden dann Advertise.
Dann Mist alle vier Minuten.
Das ist okay.
Und jetzt ist das Ding fertig.
Habe ich das jetzt auf Fahrenheit umgestellt oder was?
Ich glaube das hat Rebooted.
Und Mist angezeigt.
Ist das milliampere oder was der da anzeigt?
Was zeigt der denn da an?
Okay das ist der Batteriestand.
Und das ist die Temperatur.
So was ist das was ich da sehe?
Was ist das was sehe ich da?
48% Luftfeuchtigkeit?
Uhrzeit? Nein das ist nicht die Uhrzeit.
Was ist das?
Ist das irgendwie milliampere Stunden oder was ist das?
100 123.4 das klingt sehr nach.
Hä?
Was? Ja aber.
Was ist diese Zeile überhaupt? Was macht das?
Hä?
Ich habe wirklich keine Ahnung was soll das sein?
Was ist diese Zeile? Wofür ist die da?
Ich meine die restliche Anzeige ist vollkommen okay aber.
Was ist das?
Ist das eine Debug Anzeige oder was?
Schau.
Kein Schimmer.
Big Number.
Das ist irgendein Testmodus oder?
Das ist doch irgendein Testmodus hier.
Aber wie kriege ich den wieder aus?
Ich habe wirklich keine Ahnung was das sein soll.
Send config.
Was auch immer das ist.
Das ist ein Displaytest ja da sollte aber vielleicht nicht laufen wenn das normale läuft.
Tja.
Wie kriege ich den Displaytest denn wieder aus?
Batterie raus, Batterie rein, da merkt er sich die Settings ja nicht richtig.
Oder mal gucken ob er sich die Settings merkt.
Ich mache jetzt einfach mal Batterie raus, Batterie rein, mal gucken was passiert.
Oder hat es nicht einen Reboot Knopf?
Kann man hier Rebooten?
Reboot.
Set Default.
Set Default okay.
Set Default jetzt sollte er ja nichts machen außer Standard Anzeigen.
Das zeigt er immer noch an.
Okay Reboot gibt es hier drin nicht.
Ach ich muss erst noch Send config machen wahrscheinlich.
Okay.
Was zum Teufel ist das?
Wie man das in Home Assistant anzeigt ist nicht so einfach.
Man muss das über ein Bluetooth Gerät abfragen.
Und dann über MQTT zum Beispiel an Home Assistant schicken.
Es gibt fertige Sachen, es gibt fertige Sachen die das können.
Ich glaube ESP Home kann es mittlerweile.
Blablabla.
Muss man auf GitHub gucken.
Es gibt mittlerweile schon Sachen die das abfragen können.
Okay Leute.
Ich mache mal kurz die Batterie raus und wieder rein.
Das ist gerade nicht normal.
Ah guck mal hier.
Es ist auf jeden Fall nicht mehr prickt.
Da bin ich schon mal froh drüber.
Es funktioniert einfach.
Okay.
Reconnect.
Da sind wir.
Okay zeig dir diesen Mist jetzt wieder an.
Nee.
Okay jetzt anscheinend gut.
Jetzt zeig dir den Kram nicht an.
Alles klar.
Okay.
Advertising Interval 60.
Wir zeigen die Batterie an und sagen.
Send config.
So scheint scheint zu funktionieren.
Ich will jetzt noch mal kurz gucken wie weiter sich die Einstellung merkt.
Wir machen jetzt noch mal die Batterie raus und dann die Batterie noch mal rein.
Ja so passt das.
Der wechselt quasi die Luftfeuchtigkeit ab mit der Batterie.
Das finde ich gut.
Das ist nice.
Ja so ist das so ist das gut.
So.
Jetzt wollen wir noch mal die Batterie raus und wieder rein und gucken was sich davon gemerkt hat.
Raus und.
Nicht runterfallen.
Monka.
Wieder rein.
Anscheinend merkt er sich das guckt er zeigt die Batterie an.
Wir können den Intervall noch einstellen.
Reconnect.
Der hat die Batterie angezeigt.
Das heißt der merkt sich die Einstellung auch bei einem Neustart.
Aber.
Moment das geht nur das geht nur bis 10 Sekunden hoch.
Ach Maximum ist 10 Sekunden.
Oder wie.
What the fuck.
Warum.
Warum ist das maximale 10 Sekunden.
Auf der anderen Seite wisst ihr wisst ihr was eigentlich noch besser wäre.
Wir machen die wir machen die Batterie aus.
Die Batterie sehe ich ja über mein Home Assistant.
Wir machen die Refresh Rate hoch auf 15 Sekunden.
Weil wenn er die Batterie nicht anzeigen muss muss er muss er nicht oft wechseln.
Oder was auch so wir können wir können es eigentlich auf 30 Sekunden hoch machen.
Man updatet es halt oder sagen wir 15 wir waren 15.
So und das müssen wir aber auf jeden Fall.
Ach so Maximum ist was.
Maximum ist 12.
12 12 12 Sekunden machen wir das hoch.
Aber hier den müssten wir hoch machen.
Weil.
Also mal 10 also auf jeden Fall schon mal mal 6.
Dann ist das alle 60 Sekunden.
Ja mal 12 sind dann sind dann alle 2 Minuten.
Das ist doch das ist doch schon mal ganz sinnvoll mal 12.
Dann misst er nur alle 2 Minuten.
Allein schon mit diesen Settings würde man jetzt extrem viel Batterie sparen.
Der sollte jetzt aber eigentlich die die Batterie nicht mehr anzeigen.
Habe ich ausgeschaltet.
Aber vielleicht braucht er zum aktualisieren einfach eine Weile.
Also er sollte sich jetzt aktualisieren.
Bloß alle.
Zwei Minuten.
Ne Advertising aktualisieren sollte sich alle 12 Sekunden.
Ja gut.
Nice oder.
Richtig richtig pock.
Ich weiß ja dass ich das richtig geil finde.
Das ist mal so richtig Open Source Zusammenarbeit wie das sein muss.
Ich probiere den Kram aus im Stream stelle fest es funktioniert nicht.
Der Chat hat nachgeguckt es gab schon ein GitHub Issue dafür.
Ich habe mir den Kontakt rausgesucht von dem Entwickler.
Hab den Entwickler angeschrieben habe ihm ein paar Testgeräte geschickt.
Der war richtig auf Zack Big Brain am Start hat es gefixt.
Und ein paar Wochen später haben wir eine neue Firmware Version am Start.
Von denen alle was haben.
Und unsere Geräte gehen.
Also besser besser besser kann man es eigentlich nicht wollen oder.
Open Source als Intended ja.
Was ist das für Franzosen Musik hier.
Hört sich irgendwie so an.
Wunderbar funktioniert pock ich bin ich bin begeistert wunderbar.
Der Entwickler sucht derzeit nach einem Job.
Ja da kann ich leider ihm nicht helfen beim.
Wenn ich freien Job selber würde ich ich habe da leider nichts mit zu tun.
So und jetzt gucken wir uns noch die neuen Home Assistant Patch Notes an.
Aber vorher noch mal was schauen nämlich bei.
Ihr MQTT Geräte.
Der Cool Champ.
Nice.
Mein Home Assistant hat gleich das neue Thermometer Discovert.
Direkt.
Direkt Discovert.
Also da muss ich sagen das habe ich doch durchaus gescheit programmiert.
Ich habe dem ich lasse den Matchen auf Mac Adressen auf.
Xiaomi Mac Adressen und dann auf Bluetooth messages was da an Geräte ID drin steht.
Grafana geht nicht.
Und das funktioniert.
Ich habe jetzt das neue Thermometer schon im Home Assistant.
Ja das ist cool das ist richtig pock nice.
Nein Bluetooth ist beim Raspberry Pi 1 nicht an Bord.
Ich glaube was war das gerade.
Bluetooth gibt es glaube ich erst ab dem Raspberry Pi 3.
Ja der 2 hatte auch kein Wi-Fi.
Der 1 und der 2 hatte glaube ich noch kein Wi-Fi.
Wi-Fi gibt es erst ab dem 3 oder ab dem 0W.
0W.
Es ist zwar merkwürdig dass das LCD sich alle 12 Sekunden refresht.
Und er misst allerdings nur alle 2 Minuten.
Aber gut.
Who cares.
Ich sage da nichts passt schon.
Wahrscheinlich ist das Hardware Limitierung.
Verwendest du auch die Integration Passive BLE Monitor.
Nein.
Die kenne ich nicht.
Passive BLE Monitor.
Ne die kenne ich nicht.
Ich habe einen eigenen ESP der das abfragt.
Ahja.
Ist eigentlich eine ziemlich gute Idee.
Vielleicht soll ich das mal verwenden.
Der wird das ja genauso machen wie ich das mit meinem ESP mache.
Permanent lauschen und dann weiter schicken.
Ja die haben auch mal eine Waage.
Das ist cool.
Die Sache ist nur die.
Dann macht ihr.
Ach Moment.
Das ist eine Home Assistant Integration.
Ich dachte das ist eine ESP Firmware.
Ne eine Home Assistant Integration will ich dafür nicht verwenden.
Mein Home Assistant steht im Serverraum relativ weit weg.
Da würde ich mich nicht darauf verlassen dass der Bluetooth alles discovert.
Das muss bei mir schon auf dem ESP laufen.
Nice.
So jetzt gucken wir uns mal.
Jetzt gucken wir uns mal das aktuelle Home Assistant Release an.
Ist gerade eben rausgekommen.
Die haben ja umgestellt vor einem Jahr auf diese Ubuntu Benamung.
Das ist Schwachsinn.
Wir scrollen da schnell drüber.
Das dauert 5-10 Minuten.
Welcher ESP hat Low BLE?
Der ESP32.
Ich glaube der ESP S2 und S3 haben es auch.
Aber ESP32 auf jeden Fall.
Ich würde den ESP32 empfehlen für sowas.
Es gibt auch fertige Projekte für ESP32, BLE, MQTT.
Sowas hier in der Richtung.
Da gibt es ein paar Projekte.
Muss man mal ein bisschen durchschauen die sowas machen.
Aber die hatten alle Probleme.
Die gingen nicht richtig passiv.
War das nicht mal so ein Montana Black Meme für ein paar Jahre?
Ist das eigentlich so passiv?
Ich glaube das ist nicht mehr angesagt.
Ich kriege die Sachen immer noch mit 50 Jahren Verspätung mit.
Da muss man mal gucken.
Ich habe den Kram selbst programmiert.
Weil es gab nichts was passiv scannt.
Die haben sich alle immer drauf connected und das fand ich dumm.
Deswegen habe ich da selbst was gebastelt.
Ich glaube das haben wir nicht sogar im Stream gebaut zusammen.
Nein, nein, nein.
Der Cool Champ.
Der Cool Champ ist es glaube ich.
Yes, yes, I trust.
Der Cool Champ ist es, ja.
Das ist es hier.
Wartet mal hier.
Also das ist 253 Zeilen lang die Firmware dafür oder der Sketch heißt das ja.
Das ist wo wir Bluetooth abgefragt haben.
Das ist das was da drauf läuft immer noch.
Ja.
MQTT Passwort liegt.
Ich habe keine Ahnung was wir da genau getrieben haben wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Oh ja wir haben Bluetooth Sachen decoded.
Oh das war abartig.
Ich erinnere mich noch dran.
Dazu gibt es den Watt bestimmt.
Aber ich weiß den Titel hier.
Muss man immer schief gucken in diesem Google Docs Text Dokument.
Da gibt es garantiert einen Watt zu.
Ach du Scheiße.
MonkaS.
Da kann ich mich überhaupt nicht mehr dran erinnern.
Wir haben Bits geschiftet.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Data 0.
Your logical end.
Ach du große ich habe keine Ahnung mehr was ich da gemacht habe.
Big Brain Big Magic ja.
Ich habe wirklich kein.
Das habe ich mir doch bestimmt.
Das habe ich ich weiß es noch.
Ich habe mir das teilweise abgeguckt auf GitHub von anderen Leuten die es schon implementiert haben.
Ja ja das weiß ich noch.
Gespickt.
Ah ja.
Obviously.
Data value start plus eins nach links acht nach links geschiftet logical or data value start.
Obvius.
Vollkommen klar was es tut.
Also wer das nicht weiß sollte aninstallen.
Dann aus irgendwelchen Gründen durch zehn geteilt.
Ach das ist die unterschiedliche Geräte die wir hier abgefragt haben.
Das geht ja für Waage und für.
Oh man.
Ja und hier fragen wir die Batterie ab.
Update Battery Level.
Meine Güte.
Ich will es.
Ich will es gar nicht sehen.
So ekliche Sachen.
Block Home Assistant.
Auf geht's.
Gucken wir uns mal die aktuelle Version an.
Agile 10 von 10.
Ja finde ich auch.
Richtig.
Next Level.
Agile.
Poggers.
Poggers Q Chat.
Extreme Programming.
Dass wir müssten wir müssten hier unsere Methode.
Irgendwie verkaufen als irgendwie super agil.
Also das ist ja quasi eine Art von per Programming was wir hier machen.
Also ich programmiere und der Chat guckt zu.
Und sagt ab und zu Max.
Das ist scheiße was du machst.
Das kann so nicht funktionieren oder was was vergessen.
Und.
Das müssten wir verkaufen als das braucht.
Irgend ein gutes Agile Agile Name.
Also also Q Chat Programming können wir das nicht nennen.
Das ist nicht stonks genug.
Das braucht richtig griffigen Business Namen.
Crowdsourcing.
Irgendwas mit Crowdsourcing vielleicht.
Crowdsourced Development oder so.
Nee das klingt nach Pfeiffer.
Nach Pfeiffer klingt das.
Blockchain.
Ja Blockchain sollte auch auf jeden Fall rein in den Namen.
Fällt mir nichts gutes zu ein.
Ok also gucken wir uns mal die Home Assistant Patchnot an.
Ich lasse mal hier die Kamera eingeblendet.
Weil erstens kann ich euch dann winken.
Und außerdem passt das genau hier an den Text.
Q Chat Crowdsourced Coding.
C C C C.
Das klingt fast zu Kokomret.
Agile Distributed Cloud Programming.
Ja das ist gut.
Das ist gut.
ADCP.
Das ist eine gute Abkürzung.
Die gibt es glaube ich noch nicht.
ADCP.
Oh was ist das?
Natürlich gibt es das.
Es gibt alle Abkürzungen schon.
Ein Ultraschall Doppelprofil Strömungsmesser.
ADCP.
Ja aber ADCP.
Agile Distributed Cloud Computing.
Cloud Programming.
Das finde ich super.
Das sollten wir so machen.
Yep.
Weißt du welcher Stream das war?
Du musst mal im Archiv gucken.
Wublords.TV.
Da gibt es ein Google Docs Dokument.
Und ich vermute mal, dass der Titel irgendwas war.
Machst du noch die Steckdose?
Ja vielleicht.
Vielleicht mache ich die auch im nächsten Stream.
Das weiß ich nicht.
Je nachdem wann Bedgetime ist.
Google.
Come on.
Wo ist das Problem?
Mach.
Oh ne das ist bestimmt TOS Musik.
Keine Ahnung.
Worktime.
Warum ist der Afternoon Walk vor Worktime?
Das doch ist nicht aktuell.
Das liegt daran, dass der Sebaro mit seinem Physikgrill beschäftigt.
Aber das macht nichts.
Das ist so alt.
Cool.
Champ.
ESP.
Wassersensor.
Smarter.
Bis wann geht denn dieses Dokument?
4.2021.
Warum ist das nicht aktualisiert?
Was ist da los?
Kühlschranksensor.
Da ist es doch.
Kühlschranksensor mit etwas, das dafür nicht gedacht ist.
Und keine Lust darauf hat.
Warum?
Wie kann man da keine Lust drauf haben?
So was ist doch voll spaßig.
Also verstehe ich nicht.
Vielleicht sollte man das mal.
Du lädst die Worts manuell runter.
Das heißt da ist noch der Titel dabei, oder?
Dann könnte man doch ein LS machen und sich die Titel daraus kleppen.
Und dann einfach 50 Zeilen Copy Paste.
Ja.
Ich könnte das schon mal nicht machen, weil ich habe die Streams ja gar nicht mehr.
Weißt du, was du machen kannst, Stripes?
Mach einen LS auf das Verzeichnis und schick mir den Paste Bin.
Dann greppe ich das selbst raus.
Schick mir den Paste Bin Link im Mod-Channel oder so auf dem Discord.
Einfach von der LS Ausgabe aus dem Verzeichnis.
Ok.
Home Assistant Release 2021.11.
Nice.
Das kam gerade eben erst raus, wie ich das sehe.
Ich habe die auch alle nicht lokal.
Die werden nach dem Upload immer gelöscht.
Keine Ahnung.
Dann dann irgendwie bei Google Drive.
Das zeigt mal her.
Also, es ist November.
Blablabla.
Es ist mir eigentlich alles wurscht.
The Frank war das wieder.
Also, es gibt ein Daylight Saving Pack.
Wer hätte das gedacht, als hätten Zeitzonen und Programmieren in irgendeiner Art und Weise
schon mal zusammen längere Zeit fehlerfrei funktioniert?
Das wundert mich überhaupt nicht.
Zeitzonen und generell Date-Time Geschichten ist der painst champ in the ass, Alter.
Also, schlimmer geht es nicht.
Eine Archiv-Automatisierung zu programmieren.
Doch, das können wir alles machen.
Aber ich muss so viel, so 3000 Themen lieber noch haben.
Und da habe ich mir noch überhaupt keine Gedanken zugemacht.
Also, es wäre mir recht, wenn es erst mal so funktioniert, wie es bisher funktioniert hat.
So, also.
Es gibt übrigens einen schönen Vortrag von John Skeet zu diesem Thema, was Zeitzonen angeht.
Wenn ich weiß, wer John Skeet ist.
John Skeet ist der Typ mit den meisten Stack Overflow-Punkten von allem.
Der ist quasi uneinholbar auf Platz 1 auf Stack Overflow.
Stack Overflow John Skeet.
Der Kerl hat 1.293.000 Reputation auf Stack Overflow.
Das ist so brutal viel, das geht eigentlich gar nicht.
35.000 Antworten.
Wer hat Platz 2?
Guck mal, der ist immer noch ab und zu aktiv.
Wer hat Platz 2? Wo sieht man das überhaupt?
Wo kann man das sortieren?
Batches.
Hier vielleicht?
Ah ja.
Was?
Total.
Also Platz 2, Platz 2 hat, ja haben die hier.
Aber der ist schon krass drauf.
Guck mal, wie sehr das dann abfällt.
Die Top 30 haben die Hälfte von ihm.
Das ist nicht wirklich dicht.
Also das ist schon ein bisschen Abstand.
Also es ist krass.
Zumindest der Typ hat auch mal einen guten Beitrag gemacht über Daytime.
Fand ich sehr spannend.
Der hat zum Beispiel in diesem Vortrag erzählt, dass die Schweden,
keine Ahnung, 1250 oder so, im Jahr 1200 oder irgendwas,
oder ne 1400, keine Ahnung, hatten die mal in 30 in Februar in Schweden,
weil sie Krieg geführt haben und vergessen haben, ihren Kalender umzustellen.
Und da haben die sich gedacht, okay, wir führen einfach in 30.
Februar ein, um das wieder auszugleichen.
Kann immer passieren.
Und der hat einen Vorteil über Daytime-Library-Skull.
Der ist richtig gut.
Also Daylight-Saving-Bug.
Was ist das Problem?
Nein, also nicht, dass ich es wüsste.
Daylight-Saving-Tempting-Causing-Homelessness-to-Crash?
Nö.
Nichts von gemerkt.
Also nichts, nichts, nichts gemerkt.
Deine CPU drehte am Rad.
Ich muss mal nachher nachgucken.
Vielleicht der meine auch und ich habe es bloß nicht gemerkt.
Geht es von allein wieder weg?
Oder ist es voll am Eskalieren?
Ich gucke mal kurz nebenbei meinem Home Assistant, wie es da aussieht.
Supervisor-System.
Nö.
Ich habe 1,1% CPU-Core-Nutzung.
Also ich hatte da wohl kein Problem mit.
Das soll mir recht sein.
Nö.
Soll mir recht sein.
Also Probleme hatte ich nicht.
Keine Ahnung.
Also jetzt kommt die Interessante.
Visit Devices and Services.
Also wenn man Geräte hat und die IP-Adresse nicht weiß.
Nö.
Ich habe das anders gelöst.
Ach, das ist cool.
Ja, das ist nice.
Also ich habe das bisher immer so gemacht.
Ich habe in den ganzen Integrations, da konnte man meistens schon einschalten, dass die IP angezeigt wird.
Aber so ist es natürlich noch besser, wenn du jetzt direkt einen Link im Web-Interface zum Device hast.
Also zum Beispiel, wenn wir hier auf unseren Test Home Assistant gehen, keine Ahnung, Integration, MQTT, Heizchamp.
So.
Hier steht jetzt bloß der Name vom Gerät.
Und hier unten drunter gibt es jetzt am nächsten, wenn das Device ein Web-Interface hat, einen Link Öffne Device.
Das ist praktisch.
Da muss man die IP nicht raussuchen.
Wobei ich es halt bei mir so gelöst habe, dass ich überall, wo es ginge, die IP schon anzeigen lasse.
Aber das ist nützlich, ja.
Das ist jetzt nicht huge krass über mega neue Poggers Neuerungen, aber das ist praktisch.
So.
Deep Link to Specific Page.
Okay.
50 Integrations haben Support für dieses neue Web-Interface.
Okay, nice.
Entity Kategorien.
Oh, das ist für Leute, die Ordnung haben wollen in ihrem Home Assistant.
Da habe ich keine Ordnung.
Das einzige, was ich mache, ist die Geräte irgendwie sinnvoll benennen, wie in dem Fall Heizung oder so.
Oder hier Shitbox oder Fernseher oder so zum Testen.
Also, ich benenne die Geräte hier sinnvoll, den Rest lasse ich einfach randomize, wie er vorgeschlagen wird.
Ja, ne.
Das glaube ich nicht für mich.
Okay.
Ach, so meinen die das.
Jetzt verstehe ich, dass die in der Übersicht ist, dass besser gruppiert, wenn die jeweilige Integration das mit schickt.
Okay, das ist natürlich sinnvoll.
Dass es dann quasi gruppiert ist nach Batterie, Konfigurationseinstellungen, Controls und so.
Ja, nice, aber ist jetzt für mich nicht so, das Ding.
Ich steuere hier drüber eh nichts, ich habe alles im Dashboard.
Das mache ich vielleicht einmal, um zu gucken, ob es funktioniert.
Okay.
Ganz viele Integrations unterstützen das jetzt, okay.
Es gibt einen Icon Picker.
Oh, das ist cool.
Moment, das habe ich jetzt gar nicht gesehen.
Zeig nochmal.
Nice, endlich.
Das ist cool.
Ich musste bisher immer auf die Material Design Icons gehen und raussuchen, was ich für einen Icon für meine Geräte nehme, wenn das Standard nicht gepasst hat.
Das ist eine nice Neuerung.
Das ist jetzt zwar Feature technisch nichts Neues, aber wie sagt man, Quality of Life, keine Ahnung, also Changes.
Ja, das ist gut.
Usability, genau, das ist ja praktisch. Ja, das finde ich nice.
Was sind denn die Hue Icons und die Arrenslop Icons?
Okay.
Ich benutze immer die Material Design.
Ach so, bei.
Immer die Material Design Icons und passt.
Okay, Tuya Update.
Ohje, China, Chinesen, Cloud Zeug.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich das jetzt lesen will.
Also die neue Tuya Integration war anscheinend kacke.
Okay, die China Chinesen haben die Deadline für ihre Deprecated API um sechs Monate verschoben.
Das heißt, wer die Tuya Integration verwendet, ja, die haben noch ein bisschen Zeit und wollen jetzt eine bessere Integration bauen.
Okay, ein weiterer Grund, warum ich meine Gegäte flashe.
In den letzten Release Notes haben die gesagt, haben die gesagt, die Tuya Integration ist richtig nice und die wird auch maintained von den China Chinesen.
Da hätte ich schon gleich sagen können, wenn die, wenn die, die Tuya Leute aus China so eine Integration programmieren, dann kann das nichts werden.
Also da habe ich wenig Vertrauen in die.
Wer nutzt schon Tuya Zeug ohne zu flaschen?
Gar nicht so wenige, weil du kannst eben viele Geräte nicht mehr flaschen.
Und Noobs natürlich.
Ja, natürlich.
Und Leute, die nicht so einfach mal hier Geräte flaschen.
Aber viele Sachen kannst du gar nicht mehr flaschen.
Okay.
Ja, juckt mich jetzt aber nicht, verwende ich nicht.
Nice Template Filters.
Ohje, was? Hä? Big Brain Time.
Ach, das sind die so Pyson Templates im in der in der Konfig, die verwende ich eh nicht.
Okay, es gibt irgendwie neue Helper für Date Time.
Es gibt irgendwelche Array Helper.
Ja, gut.
Wenn ich brauche, dann brauche ich es, ansonsten brauche ich es eher nicht.
Erst recherchieren, dann kaufen, kriegen leider viele nicht hin.
Ich glaube, viele Leute haben gar keine Ahnung davon.
Also wenn wenn ich wenn man sich die Amazon Bewertung anguckt.
Die kommen glaube ich von Amazon.
Hier zum Beispiel zum Beispiel ihr guckt also wo habe ich es denn hier.
Amazon Bewertung hier von so einer von so einer China Steckdosenleiste.
Das sind zu 90 Prozent Noobs, die nicht mal wissen, dass es Custom Filmer für sowas gibt.
Die haben keine Ahnung.
Die verwenden die Smart Life App und ärgern sich dann, dass wenn die Internet ausfällt, sie ihre Steckdose nicht mal schalten können, weil es nach China muss.
Selbst schuld, ja, aber die wissen sie wissen es einfach nicht besser.
Und ich glaube, die kommen gar nicht auf die Idee, dass man Geräte mit Custom Firmware fleschen kann oder so.
Die wissen gar nicht, dass das Wort was das Wort Custom Firmware bedeutet und auf die Idee ihren Staubsauger zu fleschen.
Ich glaube, da kommen die erst recht dann auch nicht.
Ja, also ich verstehe schon, warum es das gibt.
Aber mir kommen die Dinge auch nicht ins Haus ohne, dass ich sie fleschen kann.
Deswegen habe ich mir jetzt ja noch einen Fünfer Pack von dieser Steckdosenleiste bestellt, weil das die letzte Steckdosenleiste ist auf Amazon, die sich noch OTA Tasmota fleschen lässt.
Darf sich davon Hammer nicht irritieren lassen oder ich sprühe mich aus Hammer Hammer wie auch immer.
Das ist die gestinkt normale Kugik China Steckdosenleiste, die ich auch schon vorher gekauft habe von ein paar anderen Herstellern.
Genau die gleiche und das Gute ist halt, die lässt sich noch Tasmota fleschen.
Heute sein Dankeschön für den Zapp.
Sorry, falls ich hier Subscribes Subscriptions übersehen habe.
Boah, ich werde müde hier.
Was sind denn gute Preise für den Raspberry Pi 3?
Ich kann jetzt aus dem Kopf nicht sagen.
Keine Ahnung.
Guck Geiz Hals, ich wollte gerade sagen, guck auf den Preis Champ, aber der bringt dir bei Raspberry Pi nichts.
Welche Staubsauger Firmware hast du?
Ja, die von Hypefor, der gerade im Chat war.
Die hier, guck.
Die da.
Die habe ich auf meinem Roborock S5.
Nein, da kann man die neuen nicht mal gescheit fleschen.
Magst, wie du sagst, am Anfang deiner Videos nur noch Hallo Leute, Herr Schatz Jungs und Mädels.
Da ist weniger Gedanken reingeflossen, wie glaube ich manche Leute haben.
Aber es hat auch nichts mit irgendwelcher, was weiß ich, neu entdeckter Diversity Geschichte oder so zu tun.
Ich habe vor einem Jahr ja wieder angefangen regelmäßig Videos zu machen und irgendwie war es mir danach einfach meine Begrüßung ein bisschen zu updaten.
Das hat keinen tieferen Sinn.
Wenn ich mal korrekt ist, müsste ich ja heute sagen, was ist denn die korrekte Ansprache, wenn ich alle Leute ansprechen möchte?
Hallo liebe ZuschauerInnen, oder was macht man da jetzt?
Hallo MWD, ZuschauerInnen.
Hallo ZuschauerInnen, aber das ist auch gut.
Wisst ihr, diese ganze Gender-Thematik, das wird eigentlich viel zu heiß gekocht alles.
Das ist halt so ein simples Thema, da kann jeder was zu sagen, da kann sich jeder darüber aufregen.
Letztendlich unterm Strich ist es eigentlich ein ziemlich unbedeutendes Thema.
Ob man jetzt gendert oder nicht, das kann jeder machen, wie er will.
Das ist eigentlich komplett irrelevant für die gesamte Menschheit.
Aber da kann jeder was zu sagen, da ist jeder entweder voll dafür oder voll dagegen oder regt sich auf.
Ich persönlich handhabe das relativ pragmatisch.
Ich gendere normalerweise nicht nur dort, wo es einen Vorteil bringt.
Ein Vorteil ist zum Beispiel, wenn man auf Twitter ein Zeichenlimit hat.
Wenn man zum Beispiel ein Zeichenlimit hat, wenn man gerade wieder über die Bahn flamen ist
und nicht Manager und Managerinnen schreiben kann, aber explizit erwähnen möchte,
dass man echt alle meinen und alle Kacke findet.
Dann würde ich wegen dem Zeichenlimit einfach schreiben ManagerInnen zum Beispiel. Warum nicht?
Also ich finde, das ist ein Tool, was man sich da geschaffen hat für die Sprache,
was man eben verwenden kann oder auch nicht. Und halt, wenn es an einer Stelle sinnvoll ist,
weil es irgendwas einem hilft, warum sollte man es nicht verwenden?
Aber normalerweise verwende ich es nicht, wie gesagt, bloß da, wo es irgendwas bringt.
Zum Beispiel, weil man auf Twitter Zeichenbegrenzung hat.
Otto hat einen Shitstorm bekommen. Twitter ist immer am Shitstorm.
Du kannst Twitter nicht benutzen ohne Shitstorm, deswegen habe ich es ja auch auf Andorra stehen.
Magst du Anime? Natürlich.
Ehrlich gesagt, ich kenne mich da nicht so gut aus.
Ich habe in meinem Leben nicht viele Animes geguckt.
Was habe ich denn geguckt? Lass mal überlegen, was habe ich Animes geguckt?
Ich habe die allererste Fullmetal Alchemist Serie geguckt.
Nicht die zweite, die erste, die es damals gegeben hat.
Ja, noch ein paar Sachen, aber nicht viel, nicht viel.
Ja, warum man sich da drüber aufregt, wie schlimm das ist, ich meine,
ich finde, das ist eigentlich ein ziemlich unbedeutendes Thema.
Ich finde, man sollte das jedem überlassen, wie er das machen will.
Sobald man anfängt, das irgendwie krampfhaft den Leuten aufzuzwingen, finde ich blöd.
Ich denke, wenn das was Sinnvolles ist, wird sich das mit der Zeit eh durchsetzen.
Aber was ich nicht für sinnvoll halte, ist, es gibt ja Umfragen,
ich glaube 70% oder so sagen, sie finden das bescheuert,
dann quasi die Leute erziehen zu wollen und zu sagen, hier,
wenn wir jetzt die nächste Klassenarbeit schreiben, müsst ihr das machen,
sonst gibt es Punkteabzug oder sowas.
Falls das passiert, keine Ahnung, ob sowas passiert, dann fände ich das nicht gut.
Aber ansonsten würde ich das jedem selbst überlassen, wie er das machen will.
Wie gesagt, ich mache es normalerweise auch nicht, außer dort, wo es praktisch ist.
Letztendlich muss man Sprache als Tool verwenden,
um seine Gedanken zu übertragen in andere Köpfe.
Dafür ist es ja da.
Also Sprache, egal ob gesprochen oder geschrieben, ist ja dafür da,
dass du das, was du bei dir im Kopf denkst,
schaffst in den Kopf eines anderen zu transferieren.
Und da kann so viel schiefgehen dabei, das ist man sich, glaube ich, gar nicht im Klaren.
Deswegen, es gibt so viele Sachen, die kommen bei dem anderen anders an,
als man sie gemeint hat, aber ist ja klar,
der kann ja einem das nicht ins Hirn auslesen.
Dann, wenn man sich das mal überlegt, man denkt sich jetzt irgendwas.
Dann muss man sich überlegen, okay, wie verpacke ich das jetzt am besten in deutsche Wörter?
Dann musst du diese deutschen Wörter aneinanderreihen, sinnvolle Sätze draus machen.
Dann musst du die aussprechen, möglichst so, dass man sie gut versteht.
Dann muss das Ganze über die Luft übertragen werden als Schallwellen.
In das Ohr von dem Typ, der es hört,
der muss daraus wieder deutsche Wörter machen, Sprache, gucken, dass er das versteht.
Und dann diese Wörter wieder nach Möglichkeit dem gleichen Gedanken,
den du hattest, in seinem Kopf zurückkonvertieren.
Kein Wunder, dass die Leute so oft aneinander vorbei reden.
Das kann ja gar nicht richtig funktionieren.
Guck mal, wie viel kann denn, da kann so viel schiefgehen.
Kein Wunder, dass die Leute sich die ganze Zeit missverstehen.
Und man muss sich mal überlegen, es ist erstaunlich, wie gut das funktioniert.
Zum größten Teil funktioniert das ja ziemlich ausreichend.
Ich will nicht sagen ziemlich gut, aber ausreichend gut.
Also, naja.
Okay, wir waren aber eigentlich bei Home Assistant Patch Notes.
Also, weitere wichtige Changes. Was haben wir denn sonst noch zu bieten?
Debug, Traces, Automation, Scripts und All Stored. Okay, nice.
Number Entity kann man jetzt Slider anstatt Input Box machen. Okay.
Es gibt jetzt Lüftergruppen. Alles klar.
Man kann abfragen, welche Integrations man hat. An oder aus. Ja, gut.
Oh, wir haben jetzt Initial Support for Web ATC Streams and Cameras.
Das ist cool.
Vielleicht kann ich meine custom gestrickte Kameralösung ja doch irgendwann mal rausschmeißen.
Weil die Home Assistant Kamera Integration ist, finde ich, eines der schlechtesten, die sie haben.
Also ansonsten, ich bin riesen Home Assistant Fan, aber die Kamera Integration ist Müll.
Das ist zum größten Teil halbe Minute hinten dran.
Dann so komische, es ist glaube ich entweder, es glaube ich entweder HTS Streaming oder Motion JPEG.
Also, i. Web ATC ist einfach pock.
Vielleicht kann ich wirklich bald das rauskicken, meine eigene Anwendung da mit Web ATC Kamera zu Web ATC.
Wahrscheinlich nicht. Wahrscheinlich wird mir irgendwas nicht dran gefallen.
Nest Battery interessiert mich nicht.
Material Design Icons neu.
Pad Care supportet irgendwas. Keine Ahnung, was die herstellen.
Ob Katzenklappen oder Katzenkloß oder kein Schimmer.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es smarte Katzenkloß gibt.
MQTT, Broadlink Integration, WLED.
WLED Integration hat jetzt Sliders, wo man die Effektintensität und Speed einstellen kann.
Okay, das ist praktisch, wenn man das über Home Assistant machen will.
Ich verstell da normalerweise nichts, aber das ist praktisch, dass es jetzt nicht nur über WLED geht, sondern über die Home Assistant Integration.
Open Garage.
Garage, je nachdem, wen du fragst.
Open Garage, keine Ahnung, was das sein soll.
Wahrscheinlich für Leute, die eine Garage haben.
Ich hab übrigens auch eine Garage, aber da steht kein Auto drin, sondern, äh, ja, Zeug, was ich aufheben will.
Mein Auto steht in, also, nee.
Ich glaube, jetzt mal ernsthaft, ich glaube, ich hab mein Auto noch nicht einmal seit 2013, seit ich hier wohne, in die Garage gefahren.
Das steht entweder im Hof oder auf der Straße.
Und nicht in der Garage.
Äh, VLC Integration gibt's?
Okay, da kann man TTS, Text-to-Speech über VLC irgendwie abspielen.
Gut, benutze ich normalerweise nicht.
Long-Term-Statistik, New Integration, Look-In.
Sagt mir auch nichts.
New Integration, ah, man kann Octoprint jetzt über das UI aufsetzen, das ist cool.
Okay, das Release ist wirklich sehr minimalistisch und, äh, auf Quality of Life ausgelegt, finde ich aber gut.
Die haben teilweise, bei Home Assistant mal eine Phase gehabt, da haben die fünf Monate in Folge rausgekloppt, du bist kaum hinterher gekommen mit irgendwas.
Ich finde das sogar echt ganz praktisch, dass die auch mal normale Releases haben, wo sich nicht das halbe Programm ändert.
Finde ich nice, gefällt mir.
Ah, ich hab schon gedacht, ich hab mein Passwort geliegt, lull.
Jo.
Gut.
Ähm.
Ah, ich überlege gerade, flashen wir jetzt noch die Steckdosenleisten?
Nee, ich hab nur noch 15 Minuten Zeit, wir flashen, wir flashen nicht.
Die Steckdosenleisten flashen wir mal in einem anderen, nee, die flashen wir jetzt nicht.
Passi, wenn du sehen willst, wie mir die Steckdosenleisten flasht, guck dir, guck dir den Stream von gestern an.
Wir haben gestern genau die gleiche Steckdosenleiste geflashed.
Im Stream.
Also wenn du wissen willst, wie es geht, guck dir einfach von gestern.
Kannst ja auch schneller durchskippen.
Ah.
Das machen wir irgendwann anders.
Ist ja nicht so akut.
Kannst du Skifahren?
Ähm.
Ja.
Aber.
Ich war schon ganz lange nicht mehr Skifahren.
Ich bin jetzt 37, ich glaube, ich war mit 20 das letzte Mal Skifahren.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das noch kann.
Wahrscheinlich kann ich das noch, aber es ist schon ewig her.
Wie heißt das Programm, das gerade läuft?
Das hier.
ASCII-Quarium.
Das andere Thermometer noch flashen.
Na gut, das ist jetzt nicht so spektakulär.
Wer hat das hier?
Das andere Thermometer noch flashen.
Na gut, das ist jetzt nicht so spektakulär.
Wer hat das jetzt gesehen, wie es funktioniert?
Das funktioniert immer genauso.
Ich muss einfach diese Saison wieder.
Nee, ich glaube nicht, dass ich dieses Jahr wieder anfange mit Skifahren.
Ich meine, man darf immerhin, ja.
Vielleicht passiert das doch mal.
Weil man muss sich überlegen.
Die letzten.
So die letzten drei, vier Jahre hatte ich.
Man möchte es kaum glauben.
Hatte ich tatsächlich im Sommer Hautfarbe.
Also das hat mich selber überrascht.
Aber ich hatte tatsächlich im Sommer sowas wie braune Hautfarbe.
Also Hautdings.
Wie heißt das?
Bräunung.
Normalerweise war ich immer Käseweiß, weil ich nie rausgegangen bin.
Okay, das stimmt nicht.
Das sind nicht die letzten drei, vier Jahre.
Das sind vielleicht die letzten.
Warte mal, 2013 sind wir umgezogen.
Ja, okay, sind vielleicht doch schon.
Sind vielleicht doch schon fünf, sechs Jahre.
Oder so, wo ich angefangen habe, mich mehr zu bewegen wieder.
Aber.
Ich hatte, ich hatte jetzt, wo du sagst Sonnenbrand.
Ich hatte tatsächlich vor vor einem Jahr oder so.
Ansatzweise Sonnenbrand.
Was zum Teufel ist das?
Wisst ihr wo?
Ihr kommt nie drauf, wo ich Sonnenbrand hatte.
Oh nein, es hat nichts.
Es hat nichts mit Gachi Bass zu tun.
Also ich hatte nicht richtig.
Aber es war gerade an der Grenze an der Grenze zum Sonnenbrand.
Am Nacken.
Ja, fast fast.
Auf dem Kopf.
Ich Sonnenbrand.
Ich hab, ich hab hinten auf dem Kopf jetzt.
Sag mal, ich hab jetzt keine Klatze oder so.
Aber es ist an manchen Stellen schon etwas dünner.
So im Ansatz bei Sonnenbrand auf dem Kopf.
Deine Meinung zu risk habe ich.
Ich weiß, was es ist.
Das ist der Schiener Prozessor.
Die Schiener CPU Architektur.
Hab ich mich aber nie weiter mit beschäftigt.
Also es heißt, vielleicht ist es gar nicht so.
Aber es ist so.
Also es heißt vielleicht ist es gar nicht ausgeschlossen,
rive wieder Skifahren geben.
Jetzt.
Wo ich doch tatsächlich mich wieder mehr bewegen so richtig.
So richtig mit teilweise bis zu drei Stunden mal hier wandern gehen
und so am Wochenende.
Also.
3 Stunden laufen.
Wo gehst duocre keine Ahnung ob ich überhaupt amphangehe
Jemals.
Also, ja ich bin ja von mir selbst echt überrascht ja
Ja also leute ich bin jetzt noch zehn minuten und wir können jetzt noch ein bisschen schwätzen über alles mögliche
Steckdosenleiste, Flaschen mache ich das nächste Mal. Andere Sachen haben wir heute gemacht
Ich guck mal mal im Chat. Ich habe bestimmt, ich habe bestimmt zig tausend Sachen
Übersehen im Chat
Hast du eigentlich smarte Schalter im Einsatz? Ja
Ziemlich viele oder welche Schalter meinst du denn?
Du meinst wahrscheinlich nichts, was man smart schalten kann. Was meinst du denn genau? Smarte Schalter?
Du meinst sowas wie den Lichtschalter oder was?
Ach so, ja da habe ich aber, das stimmt da habe ich nicht viele. Ich habe ein paar Shellys verbaut, also so
WLAN Relays, da ich die normalen Lichtschalter zum schalten nehmen kann
Ich habe so einen Zigbee, zwei Zigbee Schalter
Zwei Zigbee Schalter
Mit sechs knöppen
Einfach nur weil es geht
Die machen noch nicht sonderlich viel. Es gibt hier ein, es gibt hier ein
Ein Schalter verwende ich dafür, den habe ich bei mir an der Tür hängen. Wenn ich den abends drücke geht alles aus
Fensterbeleuchtung, Ringlight, PC
Wobei PC erst nach einer gewissen Uhrzeit, nicht da ich da mittags aus Versehen mal drauf drücke, also ab 22 Uhr
Deckenlicht, das ist quasi ein guter Nachtschalter
Was ist Fensterbeleuchtung? Ich habe am Fenster RGB
Strips
in so einem Kanal
mit so ein bisschen
Diffusor davor, dass du nicht so die einzelnen LEDs genau siehst
Und da habe ich WLED Fensterbeleuchtung
Ist an an Silvester kommt das cool, an Weihnachten kommt das cool. Für Halloween hatte ich letztens angemacht
Als die Kinder es rumgelaufen sind, das war glaube ich ein Fehler, weil dann haben die bei mir geklingelt
Und dann habe ich mich tot gestellt, ich habe nicht aufgemacht
Ich habe einfach so getan, als wäre keiner da
Afk, afk gefaked
Tu auch nicht ja
Wobei ich Halloween gar nicht schlimm finde, es gibt ja so die richtigen Halloween Hater, so nach dem Auto
Die kennen die Leute, die sich so übelst so übelst aufregen, so nach dem Auto
Was sollen wir mit dem Ami-Dreck und so was, so Halloween Kacke und sich da übelst
Ich finde das gar nicht schlimm, wisst ihr warum nicht? Ich meine man muss jetzt nicht irgendwie alles nachmachen was es auf der Welt so gibt
Aber Halloween finde ich an sich gar nicht schlecht, weil es ist halt so eines der wenigen
Feste oder
Feiertage ist bei uns ja nicht
Ja, sagen wir mal Feste, die rein für Kinder gedacht sind und
Es ist doch eigentlich nichts Verwerfliches dran, das heißt aber noch lange nicht, dass ich da mitmachen muss
Ich hätte das nicht oder so, aber auf ans Fenster, ans Fenster gehen und Süßigkeiten verteilen habe ich eh keinen Bock, mal ganz davon abgesehen
Wie sieht denn das aus, wenn ich da als 37 jähriger kein ans Fenster gehe und irgendwelche Kinder Süßigkeiten verteile
Das sieht ja halt nach Penobeer aus
Das kann ich ja nicht machen
Wobei an Halloween ist das wahrscheinlich erlaubt
Ein Halloween ist das wahrscheinlich erlaubt
Wenn mein Elter ist besäuft man sich dann, ist das so? Ich wusste nicht, dass man das an Halloween macht
Ja finde ich auch, also deswegen finde ich, deswegen finde ich Halloween nicht schlecht
Das ist so eines der wenigen Feste rein für Kinder finde ich nice
Toll, weil wie gesagt, was nicht heißt, dass ich da mitmachen muss
Lieber Halloween als die heiligen drei Könige, die heilig drei Könige gehen mir auch auf den Sack, die kriegen auch kein Geld von mir
Also ich bin, meine Tür wird nicht
Versiegelt oder wie das heißt
Wie nennt man das da
Ne, gesegnet ist es ja nicht, da wenn die da ihr Zeug an die Tür malen, an meine Tür wird da nix dran gemalt
Okay, ich guck mal kurz chat, ich hab bestimmt irgendwas vergessen wieder heute
Was heute im Stream gemacht wurde, wir haben die, wir haben hier die LEDs, die LEDs in Betrieb genommen
Und wir haben
die neueste Firmware für das Thermostat endlich geflasht
ASCII-Iquarium brauchst du, ASCII-Iquarium
DSL Crash
Paints Champ, da hat's wohl gestrikt
Ne, das andere Thermometer flaschen wir jetzt nicht
Oh nee chat, die Musik, da muss jetzt einer den üblichen Witz dazu bringen
Das ist es doch oder
Ja, das ist entweder der We Shop-Channel oder irgendwie sowas
Hoffentlich ist keiner da, der diesen dummen Witz bringt
Gute Linux-Distro um Linux zu lernen, ne Ubuntu, da kannste nicht viel falsch machen
Wenn du es auf dem Desktop verwenden willst oder als Desktop-Distro verwenden willst, würde ich wahrscheinlich eher Mint nehmen als Ubuntu
Ich finde Ubuntu auf dem Desktop ziemlich am Paints Champ
So, ich scrolle jetzt mal durch, wo hier irgendeiner n' Wobblers noch gefragt hat, falls ich was übersehen hab
Ich wusste, dass das kommt, irgendeiner muss es jetzt bringen, ja
Warum machst du das mit der 1? Ja, das ist schon so lange her, das ist die Meldung
Da haben wir ein extra... da ist, warum ich die Einsen markieren und einfügen? Da haben wir ein extra Chat-Commando für, weil das oft gefragt wird
Warum machst du das mit der 1, ja das ist schon so lange her, das ist die Meldung.
Da haben wir ein extra Chatkommando für, weil das so oft gefragt wird.
So war ja, gab ja nicht so viel, oder, wenn ich jetzt so durchscrolle.
Was hast du mit deinem, ok da hab ich keine Ahnung was sich das bezogen hat.
Aber wahrscheinlich nicht das, was damit gemeint ist.
Das Thermometer ist BLE, Low Energy Bluetooth.
Ich glaube die Chatnachrichten sind jetzt so abgekoppelt vor, weiß ich gar nicht mehr
was ich da gemacht habe, wenn ich die jetzt sehe, aber uns glaube ich sparen.
Ja Leute, so siehts aus, ich geh jetzt auf, jetzt wird ne Runde gepennt, Bettke, Boomer
müde, ja so siehts aus, ok Leute wir sehen uns bis der NCU.